hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and welcome to my AZ 900 course also
known as the azure fundamentals
certification for the Azure platform so
if you're new to cloud and you don't
know anything and you want to get into
it this is the course for you because
we're going to show you how to set up
your account look over the course
services and more and as always I'd love
to hear your feedback so if you're on
Twitter or LinkedIn definitely tell me
how the course is and maybe a do pass be
sure to hashtag as your as your
certified on Twitter and I'll definitely
reach out to you I hope you pass and hey
this is Angie Brown from exam pro and
we're looking at what is the AZ 900 so
the azure fundamentals is the entry
level cloud certification for microsoft
azure the certification is generally
referred to by its course Co which is
the AZ 900 the AZ 900 is about knowing
the azure core services the fundamentals
of cloud computing and having a bit of
hands-on experience working with the
azure portal and if you look in the top
right corner that is what the
certification badge looks like once you
earn it for the azure fundamentals and
then just talking about certifications
in general Fraser if you want to have a
roadmap as to what you do after this
certification as your breaks up their
certifications their role based
certifications as fundamental associate
expert and specialty so in the
fundamentals we have the AZ 904 the
associate we have the administrator the
developer the AI engineer the data
scientists the data engineer if you
notice for data engineer you're gonna
see there's two course codes under DP
200 DP 201 because some some
certifications require you to pass two
different exams so if you want to become
a data engineer you have to pass those
two exams that the expert level or sorry
we sell the security in associate but
the expert level we have the solution
architect expert where you have two
exams you have to pass then there's the
DevOps engineer expert and then four
specialties we have Azure for SI P
workloads and IOT developer so these are
all the azure certifications that are
role-based azure or Microsoft used to
have everything that was very a service
or technology specific but things have
changed to roles which makes things a
lot easier
for people that are hiring because
people that are hiring will look and say
oh you have the data engineer
certification you must know how to do
data engineering so that is really
simplifying things you can take any of
these in any order that you like so if
you want to go to the expert level right
away you absolutely can but it's not
generally recommended it's you should
start with fundamentals associate go to
expert but you know whatever you think
is best for you that's what you have to
decide so who is the AC 904 well it's
commonly obtained by sales and
management to help inform VPS or CEOs
reasons for their company to utilize
Microsoft Azure and among developers
it's to show they have familiar
knowledge with cloud concepts so anyone
that's like if you've had a program
background but you just don't have clout
experience it's just a great way to tack
on the cloud skill there and the AZ 900
focuses on building security and
business centric concepts which makes
sense because if it's designed for sales
and management it's going to be things
that are going to help them convince to
adopt it such as like using the TCO
calculator and and informing decisions
like that like knowing SL A's and things
like that to drive business decisions so
what value does the AZ 900 hold well if
you're developer it's not going to be
that useful on your resume people aren't
gonna be trying to hire you just because
you have it you really gonna have to
move on to the associate or expert track
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't get
this one if you are a developer and you
already have cloud knowledge and another
cloud provider say you have AWS skills
you already have an associate level and
you just want to show that you can work
across cloud grabbing this certification
just shows that oh yeah okay I poked
around the azure portal so you'll have
that transferable knowledge so that
would be a good case to get it as a
developer or if you don't have any cloud
certifications and you want to make sure
the cloud provider you want to use then
that makes sense to go get the the main
reason I tell people always get a a
fundamental certification is because it
helps them build confidence before you
take a harder certification and they
also get you familiar with the exam
experienced whether you do it in person
or online because that can be extremely
stressful okay so now you're convinced
that you want to go get the AZ 900 so
you're going to be asking me well how
much
do I have to put in to gain the
certification well if you're a developer
say you know a junior to mid developer
you've been working the industry for a
few years but you don't have cloud
experience I'm gonna say that you're
gonna have to spend about eight hours of
study if you're a bootcamp grad so you
don't really have any real-world
industry experience but you want to try
to tack on cloud as early as possible to
help your resume and stand amongst the
crowd you're probably be spending 15
hours of study if you are in sales or
management so you just do not have a
technical background but you're trying
to understand why you should adopt a
sure or cloud for your business you're
looking at 20 hours of study and the way
I recommend it is you want to put one
two three hours a day for seven days and
I mean every single day you don't want
to spread this stuff out now next
question is where do you take this exam
and the way it works with most cloud
service providers is they are partnered
with a a company that is also partnered
with a bunch of test centers around the
world and the one that azor is partner
with is called Pearson VUE but the great
thing about Pearson VUE is that you can
either go in person to a test center so
you use their Pearson Pearson VUE
website and would tell you test centers
nearby or you can take it from the
convenience of your own home so if you
have a web camera and you have a very
sparse room so that you don't have a
bunch of things in the background and
they can trust that you're in a secure
location they'll let you take it from
your home office and that's what we
called a proctored exam and the reason
we call that a proctored exam is because
a proctor is a supervisor or person who
monitors students during an examination
so you have those both options available
to you if I had to choose one of the
other I would strongly recommend going
in person because online things can just
go wrong and you don't want to have that
problem but you know it just depends on
you okay and the last thing is what does
it take to pass the exam so there are
three components here the first is to
watch the video lectures and memorize
key information the second thing is to
do hands-on labs and follow along with
your own as your account I night we show
you how to set up your own account in
here but when we get to the sections
definitely you should do
just don't watch it because that's gonna
make a huge difference to help you pass
and the last is to do paid online
practice exams that simulate the real
exam you can pass the exam without using
paid practice exams at the foundation
level which is this certification it's
much harder the associate and expert
level so you're gonna have to go get a
paid solution if you are gonna go get
paid practice exams please do me the
favor and use ours because it supports
us able to produce this content so don't
go and use one of those other paid
providers that do not provide free
content because for us if we made enough
money we'd make everything free and
that's the whole point so there you go
[Music]
so now let's take a look at the exam
guide and break down what it is that
we're going to need to do to pass exam
and how we're going to have to study so
the first thing is the content outline
this is basically the general domains
we're gonna have to focus our time on
the first being cloud concepts this is
worth 15 to 25 percent of the exam then
you have azure core services this is
worth 30 to 35 percent of the exam then
you have security privacy compliance and
Trust this is 25 to 3 percent of the
exam and then you have pricing and
support which is 20 to 25 percent of the
exam you'll notice that there are ranges
here so the thing is is that it's not a
guarantee that exactly 25 percent of the
questions are gonna be of that sort so
just be aware of that then onto grading
in order to pass this exam you have to
score a 700 out of the thousand so
generally you what you're trying to get
is around 70% to pass I say around
because you could get exactly 700 and
you could fail because as your uses
scaled scoring meaning that the raw
score that you get doesn't necessarily
reflect the final score so you're gonna
want to score a bit higher than 70% so
you want to aim for 75% or higher the
type of questions you'll see on the exam
we'll talk about here in a moment
but there are between 40 to 60 questions
so that means you have you have the
chance of getting 12 to 18 questions
wrong I put an asterisk here because
people who have actually taken the exam
have reported only being
with 30 questions and I even reached out
to as your support to clarify that to
say what is the real number and their
official answer was 40 to 60 but I know
that when people are taking the exam
there their experience is different
there's not much I can do about it it's
just that's what it is it's going to be
a bit fluid in terms of what your
experience is going to be but let's just
go with this and say there's 40 to 60
questions in terms of the format of the
questions you're going to see multiple
choice you're going to see multiple
answer you're gonna see maybe drag and
drop and then you might see a hot area
hot area you usually just means like a
couple drop downs where you have to
answer two things at once and the
duration of the exam is 60 minutes so
that means you get one minute per
question roughly around that time but
the exam time is 60 minutes but the seat
time is 90 minutes so see time refers to
the amount of time that you should
allocate for the actual exam so that you
have time that includes reviewing the
instructions before you start your exam
reading accepting the NDA completing the
actual exam itself which is the exam
time 60 minutes and to provide feedback
at the end of the exam which is
generally optional and the last thing is
how long is this certification going to
be valid for and it's gonna be valid for
24 months so that means you're gonna be
able to hold on this for two years
before you have to get recertified so
there you go so now I just want to
quickly show you the exam guide they
don't call their exam guide literally
exam guide it's the Microsoft Azure
fundamental skills measured and so this
gives you pretty much the information
for the breakdowns in terms of what
stuff you might need to learn but that
doesn't mean necessarily everything that
is listed in here is actually on the
exam but let's just quickly go through
it so you have an idea so the first is
the cloud concepts domain and in here we
need to know cloud terms such as
availability scalability elasticity
fault tolerance disaster recovery
agility I haven't seen that on the exam
before but they have it listed there
then we have to describe the economics
of scale capex versus OPEX consumption
based models then you have to describe
the different types of cloud cloud
models such as infrastructure as a
service platform as a service software
as a service
we have to describe public private and
hybrid cloud models so there's that
there then you have to know a bunch of
different core services for Azure so
these ones I would call them global
infrastructure they mostly have to do
with networking then you have all your
core services here and then more core
services or extended services I suppose
then management tools then you have your
security privacy compliance and Trust so
more networking components around
security but these don't really show up
in the exam that much but I've covered
them anyway just in case then as your
identity so that's creating accounts
giving access to people the big one
there is really Azure Active Directory
then other security tools so this is
just knowing about things like the
Security Center which is a security tool
or just security services within Azure
then we have governance so this is going
to be like policies role based access
just general access that has to do but
kind of with as your identities up here
then monitoring tools then we have
compliance data protection standards
this is generally just pointing to
website so the trust Center is just a
website that lists compliance
information that we have described
pricing SLA is life cycle so
understanding the subscriptions so you
know free versus student versus
enterprise then here just a bunch of
pricing so like they have a pricing
calculator and a TCO calculator and
understanding the support plans and then
understand the SLA s and then there's
lifecycle stuff like understanding
general availability so yeah there you
go that's the that's exam guide outline
I mean they have stuff down here below
about changes doesn't really matter oh
yeah that is the exam guide outline if
you want more information about the
actual like the actual exam policies
this page is really good for that I got
this from the azure support team so it
says exam policies and fa Q's so this
would be about like retiring
certifications or like how to book your
exam or they would have information here
about retake so what would happen if you
pay for it
missed it or how many retakes would you
get or how long the exam hours are so
there's a lot of information here so if
you just want to scroll through it but
yeah here like they don't say on the
exam that's 60 minutes they just say oh
for general fundamental exams they're 60
minutes so we just have to assume that
is what that's the time you get on the
AZ 900 but yeah just check out that page
and check this out if it interests you
but you don't really have to because we
cover everything in the course you need
to know I just wanted those resources I
want to make you aware of those
resources just in case hey this is
Andrew Brown from exam pro and we're
starting at the beginning of our journey
asking the most fundamental question
which is what is cloud computing so
looking into the dictionary cloud
computing is described as the practice
of using a network of remote servers
hosted on the Internet to store manage
and process data rather than a local
server or personal computer so when
we're talking about local we describe
this as being on-premise so being your
own office or your own data center and
so this is where you own the servers you
hire the IT people you pay the rent or
the real estate you take all the risk
whereas with a cloud provider if you're
utilizing them it's someone else who
owns the servers someone else who hires
the IT people someone else who pays or
rents the real estate and you are only
left with being responsible for
configuring your cloud services and code
and someone else takes care of the rest
sounds great doesn't it so now what I
want to do is just give you a quick
overview of how servers have evolved and
what we describe as cloud computing from
a technical perspective and we'll
probably dive deeper into this later in
the course but we're just going to get a
good overview here to understand from a
business perspective so way back in the
day what we had was dedicated servers if
you wanted a server to run your web app
or your technology what you had to do is
you had to go buy a single dedicated
physical machine and that was for one
specific business and dedicated servers
are still used today but there's some
downsides with them they're very
expensive they're high maintenance
however you do get a great level custom
I customized ation and you
and you potentially can have better ha
better security based on your use case
then came along was Virtual Private
servers so we still had one physical
machine but we've and it was still
dedicated to a single business but we
figured out how to take that physical
machine and virtualize it into some
machines so now we could fully utilize
or better utilize that physical server
with running multiple apps we didn't
have to buy for different servers for 4
different apps we could easily run for
what a web apps into for virtual sub
machines then we had shared hosting and
so this made it a lot easier for anybody
who's building websites or word presses
but the idea here is that you had one
physical machine and it was shared by
hundreds of businesses so it wasn't a
single business sharing the cost it was
multiple businesses so this relies on
most tenants under utilizing the
resources though so if you had a hundred
people on a server and one person used
more of the server than the others then
you could all potentially suffer from
that case but at the very least you are
getting very very cheap servers but
there are definitely some limitations so
now coming down to cloud hosting cloud
hosting gives us the best of both worlds
so we have multiple physical machines
that act as one system which it could be
described as the cloud and that system
is a distracted way into multiple cloud
services so you get the you get
flexibility scalability it's very secure
it's very cost effective and it's highly
configurable so that is where we're at
and so that is generally what cloud
computing and cloud hosting is
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at common cloud
services so a cloud provider can have
hundreds of cloud services are grouped
into various types of services and the
four most common types of cloud services
for infrastructure as a service and
we'll talk about that is later on would
be compute so this is where you have a
virtual computer that can run
applications programs in cold a code
then you have storage so this is where
you would have virtual hard drives that
you could store files then you'd have
virtual networking because you have
these computers and storage so you need
to put them in some kind of virtual
network and then you have databases so
just imagine a database that is running
in the cloud or if you're not familiar
databases just imagine that it's Excel
in the cloud but it powers your web apps
and one thing I want you to know about
the term cloud computing is that even
though it says computing in the word at
this point we just use it as a catch-all
term so it could refer to all of these
categories so when I say cloud computing
I could be referring to compute network
storage and databases but you can also
say cloud storage cloud compute cloud
databases cloud networking and people
will know what you mean hey this is
Andrew Brown from exam pro and we are
looking at what is Microsoft so you've
probably seen this logo before and
Microsoft is an American multinational
computer technology corporation
headquartered in Redmond Washington and
Microsoft makes software phones tablets
game consoles cloud services which is
what we care about here today and they
even have a search engine and we're not
just limited to that list they have tons
of stuff but Microsoft is best known for
their operating system called windows
and they've been around since the 1970s
so they've been around for quite a while
in the tech spear so now that leads us
to the question is what is a sure so a
sure is what Microsoft calls their cloud
provider service and so it's called
Microsoft Azure or we commonly refer to
it as just a sure and so here is the
logo for it if you're wondering
what is the name behind the service it
means bright blue color of the cloudless
sky
so sure that's great and so you'll hear
me say cloud service provider frequently
it was throughout this course and it is
abbreviated to CSP but that's what Azure
is it is a cloud service provider so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the benefits of
cloud computing so what are the benefits
well we have a big list here for you
starting with cost-effectiveness so you
pay for what you consume there is no
upfront cost yet pay-as-you-go also
abbreviated as PAYG and you're sharing
the cost with thousands of a customer so
that's how you're getting that that low
low cost another benefit is that you can
go global
so launch workloads anywhere in the
world just choose your region and you
are now in the global market another
benefit is the cloud is secure the cloud
providers take care of the physical
security and cloud services can be
secure by default or you have the
ability to configure access down to the
granular level so you have a lot of
security controls that you would have
that you would normally not have where
you'd have to build out on pram now the
cloud is also known for being reliable
so you can have data backups disaster
recovery and data replication and fault
tolerance the cloud is also scaleable
you can increase or decrease your
resources and services based on the
demand the cloud is also elastic so you
can automate scaling during spikes and
and drop the demand when there is no
longer the demand for that stuff and
it's also current so the underlying
hardware and manner software is upgraded
and replaced by the cloud provider
without interruption to you and I mean
the last one there is cases of
interruption but generally fewer
interruptions then you would have on
Prem so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at the different
types of cloud computing and we have
this nice pyramid on the left hand side
to help us understand how each type
builds off the other starting at the top
of our pyramid we have
software-as-a-service
also known as SAS and this is a product
that is run and managed by the service
provider you don't worry about how the
service is maintained and it just works
and remains available so you might not
be aware of this but you probably
already are using a SAS product so
examples of that could be Salesforce or
Gmail or office 365 so those are those
are things that would be considered SAS
and these are really for customers so
it's just you wanting to use software
like general software on your computer
but in the cloud
the next category we have is platform as
a service abbreviated as past and so
here we focus on development and a
management of your applications and so
you don't worry about provisioning
configuring or understanding the
hardware or less and this is really for
people that are building apps but they
don't but they don't think about any of
the infrastructure underneath services
like this would be elastic Beanstalk on
AWS or Roku which is very popular
amongst junior developers which is a
third party service for launching web
apps and then you have the Google App
Engine so those are three examples there
and these are really for developers so
platform to service makes it easy for
developers to build apps on the cloud
without worrying about all the stuff
underneath and at the bottom we have
infrastructure as a service IAS and this
is the basic building blocks of cloud IT
so provide access to networking features
computers and data storage space don't
worry about the about IT staff data
centers and hardware and this is the
true focus of our course here its
focusing on this layer but the thing is
again on this pyramid is that ia
the infrastructure service can have
platform as a service and software
service on top of it and so examples of
infrastucture service would be a
Microsoft Azure AWS or even Oracle cloud
and so this is really intended for
administrators so that is the three
types of cloud computing and there you
go
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we were looking at the types of
cloud computing responsibilities so we
saw the three categories there but we
don't really understand what it is that
we're responsible for and what is the
cloud service provider responsible for
so let's lay out our categories and
we're gonna include on-premise into this
because technically on-premise could be
a private cloud and should be in the
category here so we have on-premise
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service and software as a service so
when we're looking at applications it's
going to be the customer's
responsibility for on-prem
infrastructure pass but when we have
software as a service the cloud service
provider is responsible for that when
looking at the data level it's going to
be the same for software as a service
the cloud service private is going to be
responsible but for the rest it's going
to be the customer and then on the next
level for the runtime it's going to be
responsible on the closet providers for
the platform as a service and software
as a service for middleware it's going
to be the same for the OS like the
operating system that is running on the
service it's going to be the same then
we get to virtualization now it's the
virtualization is responsible with the
cloud service provider and above and
then for storage it's sorcery servers
it's the same and for storage it's the
same and for networking it's the same so
you can see that on-premise you're
responsible for everything and the
farther we move up the types of cloud
computing the less responsibility you
have hey this is Angie Brown from exam
Pro and we were looking at asher's
deployment models and the first smaller
we're going to talk about is public
cloud and that's where everything is
built on the cloud service provider
you're not using anything on Prem or in
your own data centers everything is
running with an azure and generally this
is known as cloud native but for some
reason azure calls the public cloud so
that's what we're going to use in the
terminology here and so here I have an
architectural diagram where we have a
network on Azure and within that network
we have a virtual machine running and a
database running so that would be an
exam
of public cloud then we have private
clouds this is where everything is built
on the company's data centers also known
as on-premise because it's within the
premises of the organization like their
physical location and it could an
organization organization could
technically be operating their own cloud
but it would be private cloud and they
could be running some open source cloud
software that mimics what a juror would
do such as OpenStack so it looks very
similar but you just put an OpenStack in
there and it's running a virtual machine
or a server and it's also running a
database and the last on our list here
is a hybrid so with hybrid you are using
both on-premise and the cloud service
provider and they're connected together
and so there's a lot of different
networking services that you can use
that will facilitate the connection
between the two in this case we're using
Express route Express ROS is a dedicated
connection it's like having a fiber
optic line running from your on-premise
data center to the azure network so it's
just one of the ways you can connect and
if we wanted to understand like the pros
and cons I have this nice little table
here and we'll just quickly go through
it so if you're using public cloud it's
more cost effective security it's it's
creat controls are stronger by default
but some people might not find the cloud
will meet all their security
requirements because of government and
regulatory regulatory reasons not
because the cloud is not secure but it's
just those those policies for a level of
configuration it's going to be limited
based on what the cloud service provider
exposes to you still there's a lot of
configuration there it's just that if
you're if you have your own servers you
obviously can do anything and everything
with them for technical knowledge you
don't need to have as much in-depth
knowledge of the underlying
infrastructure because you're not
physically setting up servers or that
networking everything else now coming
down to private cloud private cloud is
the most expensive option on our list so
you're gonna be paying a lot of money
there for security there is no guarantee
that is a hundred percent secure because
you just don't have the same kind of
visibility that you would have with a
cloud service provider with all those
dashboards it's just so hard to build
out all that software but you could
your security compliance requirements
depending on your situation
but this is becoming less and less as
more governments and larger
organizations move over to the cloud you
can configure infrastructure exactly how
you like because you literally have
bought the hardware and do anything you
want with it and the technical knowledge
you'll have to have a serious amount of
technical knowledge you might even have
a really hard time finding the resources
to to maintain all that stuff then down
below we have the hybrid model so this
could be more cost-effective based on
what you offload to the cloud and also
the cost of actually moving data back
and forth for security you know you have
more to secure but technically some
things are easier to secure on the cloud
than it is in private so maybe you have
a boost in security you're going to get
the best of both worlds in terms of
configuration and for technical
knowledge you're gonna need to know both
the cloud and and like how to set things
up on-premise so that's the most work
there and just one more deployment model
here I just want to talk about cross
cloud this isn't something that is
listed on the actual exam but it's
something that you should understand and
know and so cross cloud is when you're
using multiple cloud providers sometimes
people refer this as multi cloud or
hybrid cloud and so I just have an
example here so there's a service called
Azure Ark and what Azure Ark does that
it extends your control plane so you can
run containers kubernetes containers on
different platforms and so you could
have AWS on left-hand side with eks and
GCP kubernetes engine and so you can be
running virtual machines and they're all
treated like they're on the same network
so cross cloud is becoming very popular
with extremely large organizations where
they they have very unique requirements
but I definitely want you to know what
that is because it just gets left out
and it's definitely something that is
part of the industry so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the concept of
total cost of ownership TCO so what is
the difference between on premise so
having your own data centers and then
using Azure and you'll notice above it
it says capex and OPEX we're going to
talk about that in the next slide but
for the time for the time being we're
gonna focus on the total cost of
ownership so to really make sense of
this I always use this graphic here and
if you're wondering what that is those
are icebergs people sometimes think they
look like teeth and so just to make this
drawing a little bit more clear I've
added some penguins and a whale so
there's no mistaking it and the reason
we're using this as a representation is
because we have the top of the iceberg
which are the cost that we're generally
concerned about but then we have those
hidden costs those costs that we're not
really thinking about that is underneath
the water and if you know icebergs they
can be really big underneath you don't
know so on the left hand side the cost
that we generally think of is the
software license fees and then for the
cloud service provider we look at the
subscription fees and so when you're
comparing these two sometimes the
subscription fees can cost more than the
software license fees so you'd think
well we should really just use on-prem
because it's more cost effective but
when we take in the total cost of
ownership all the costs involved we're
gonna see a very different picture so on
the left hand side if you are on premise
you have to deal with the implementation
the configuration and the training but
you also have to deal with the physical
security of your building you have to
pay for the hardware you have to pay for
the IT personnel you have to deal with
maintenance now on the right hand side
on the cloud you still have to do
implementation and configuration and
training but that's about it so there's
a big difference in terms of what you
have to do and you might ask okay well
what is the amount of savings well
generally people find that when they
move from on-prem to the cloud they save
75 percent that's a lot of money okay 75
percent of what you generally would
spend and so now all this stuff
left-hand side is now Asher's
responsibility you don't take care of
those anymore hours are going to take
care of it for you so that's total cost
of ownership
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we were looking at capital versus
operational expenditure so on the left
hand side we have capex so capital
expenditures on the right hand side we
have operational expenditures OPEX and
so looking on the left hand side capital
expenditure is spending money upfront on
physical infrastructure so deducting the
expenses from your tax bill over time a
lot of companies larger companies are
used to dealing with capital expenses
and they know how to work their tax bill
and so that's why a lot of people are
afraid to move over the cloud because
they're used to this this this way of
operating but let's talk about some of
the things that would be considered a
capital expense so again it's anything
that's physical and then you're buying
it with money upfront so computers so
that would be your server costs if you
were to buy hard drives that'd be your
storage costs if you bought routers
cables and switches for your network if
you were purchasing things for a backup
and archive costs if you had disaster
recovery so it like an uninterruptible
power supply would be an example that
you have your data center cost so that's
your rent cooling physical security your
technical personnel so you're hiring
people to do things for you and so with
capital expenses you have to guess
upfront what you plan to spend now let's
look at operational expenditures so
operational expenditure is the cost
associated when an on-premise data
center has put as shifted that cost to
the service provider so here in this
case it's the cloud service provider and
the customer only has to be concerned
with non-physical costs
so what's examples of OPEX costs well
leasing software and customizing
features training employees in cloud
services paying for cloud support
billing based on the cloud metrics so
compute usage and storage usage and the
advantage here is that with operational
expenses you can try a product or
service without investing equipment so
we have flexibility of investment and we
also from the previous slide we saw that
we have a huge reduction cost so there's
two reasons really good reasons to use
the cloud
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud architecture
terminologies and these are very
important to help you conceptualize the
advantages of the cloud and so we're
going to go through these terms and then
we're going to go through them again in
more detail in further slides so at the
top of our list we have availability and
this is your ability to ensure a service
remains available and this is generally
known as hi-hi being highly available or
high availability abbreviated to H a
that's a term you should know then we
have scalability so your ability to grow
rapidly or unimpeded then you have
elasticity so this is your ability to
shrink and grow to meet the demand
you have fault tolerance this is your
ability to prevent a failure then you
have disaster recovery this is your
ability to to recover from a failure and
this is known generally as high being
highly durable or high durability D R so
there you go hey this is Angie Brown
from exam Pro and we are looking at the
concept of high availability so this is
your ability for your service to remain
available by ensuring there is no single
point of failure or ensure a certain
level of performance so here I have a
technical architectural diagram that is
describing high availability so the idea
behind this is that if you have a server
which runs your web application if you
were to run redundant versions of your
server if anything happened to a single
server traffic could always be routed to
those other servers and that way your
service would remain available now
having multiple servers is great but
even what's better is having multiple
servers in multiple data centers because
something could happen to a data center
it could become unavailable because of
the networking issue so by being able to
route traffic or that way you're gonna
remain highly available and and running
a workload across multiple availability
zones and availability zones is what
azure calls their data centers ensures
that if one or two data center becomes
unavailable your service will remain
available very very common to run at
least three servers across three data
centers now how would you distribute the
traffic or
the traffic to all three and that's
where an azure load bouncer comes into
play that green triangle with the arrows
that is the representation of a load
bouncer so a load balancer allows you to
evenly distribute traffic to multiple
servers in one or more data center and
if a data center or server becomes
unavailable so unhealthy the load
bouncer will route the traffic to only
available data centers with servers so
there you go that is high availability
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the concept of high
scalability and this is your ability to
increase your capacity based on the
increasing demand of traffic memory and
computing power if you are a growing
company you're gonna have to scale up
you're gonna have to get bigger and
better servers but the there are
different types of scaling and the first
type is vertical scaling this is the
most obvious one people are going to
think of and it's called scaling up and
what we do is we just upgrade to bigger
servers we need bigger hard drives
faster computers that's a vertical
scaling but there's another kind of
scaling called horizontal scaling and
horizontal scaling is is described as
scaling out and what you're doing is
you're just adding additional servers
because we saw with the high
availability we have a load balancer we
can distribute traffic to multiple
servers and three servers can equal the
same thing as one big server so
horizontal scaling is when we add more
servers of the same size hey this is
Andrew Brown from exam pro and we're
looking at the concept of high
elasticity and this is your ability to
automatically increase or decrease your
capacity based on the current demand of
traffic memory and computing power so
this sounds a lot like high scalability
but the key difference is that it's
automatic and you can decrease the
demand not just increase it and so the
way we would do that is that we would
have a virtual server chien or server
and if we needed more servers we would
add more servers and if we need less
servers we would remove less servers and
so this is going to be accomplished
using horizontal scaling so when we say
we're scaling out this means we're
adding more servers of the same size
when we're scaling in this
removing more servers of the same size
and generally you're not going to use
vertical scaling for a high elasticity
it's just extremely difficult to to
vertically scale because if you have if
you have to increase let's say your
storage drive and then you decrease it
you could lose data so it's not a good
idea or even feasible to do vertical
scaling with high elasticity now how
would you accomplish being elastic on
Asscher while you use Azure z' vm scale
set so scale sets automatically increase
or decrease in the response to demand a
bit or based on a defined schedule and
we'll talk about those in greater detail
later in this course and then we have
SQL server or servers stretch database
these dynamically stretch warm and cold
transactional data from Microsoft SQL
Server 2016 to Microsoft Azure not
something we were going to cover but
it's generally the same concept that
skill sets do so there you go that's
high elasticity hey this is Angie Brown
from exam pro and we're looking at the
concept of high durability so this is
your ability to recover from a disaster
and to prevent the loss of data so this
could be solutions that recover from a
disaster is known as disaster recovery D
R and so I'm just going to ask you a
bunch of questions to help you think
about how to be highly durable so one
question would be like do you have a
backup so do you have a backup in place
how fast can you restore your backup
does your backup still work how how do
you ensure current live data is not
corrupt so that is the concept of high
durability there's a variety of services
to implement it so it's not just a
single service but there you go that is
the full list of cloud architecture
terminologies
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the evolution of
computing and this is going to really
help you to understand the different
layers of compute and so we're gonna
start from on the left hand side to
dedicate it and work our way all the way
to functions so what I want you to know
is that when we're talking about
dedicated this is a physical server
wholly utilized by a single customer and
so the idea is that this customer has
purchased this dedicated piece of
hardware but the thing with this is that
you have to guess your capacity so when
you buy it it's like a capital cost or
your purchasing for for like the whole
like you have to plan how you're going
to full utilize it so you're gonna
overpay and you're gonna have
underutilized servers and the reason why
is that when you first launch your app
it might be small and then you're
expected to grow into that space but
you're just not using that space until
you grow into it so it's considered
wasted if you want to upgrade beyond
your capacity this is gonna be slow and
expensive you'd literally would have to
buy a new server that's larger and then
move everything over you're going to be
limited by your operating system so
whatever operating system is installed
that's what you're going to have you're
gonna have multiple apps if you do
install multiple apps onto a dedicated
server you might have conflicts in
resource sharing but generally it's
recommended to only have a single
primary application on a dedicated
server you are going to have a guarantee
of security privacy and full utility of
the underlying resources because that is
what that's the whole purpose of having
a dedicated server is sometimes
dedicated servers where you have full
control of everything is called bare
metal and that's basically mimics what
it was like to have a server on-premise
or back in the day and they still exist
so that is dedicated we'll move on to
VMs
[Music]
so now we're moving on to virtual
machines also known as VMs and so the
idea here is that if you had a physical
server and you had the capability of
running virtual machines that's like
running a machine within a machine and
so now you're able to run multiple
applications on a single machine the
technology that's used to actually run
vm's is known as hypervisor there sir
there are some other kinds but the ones
we need to know is hypervisor so just
know that that's the software that makes
virtual machines work you are now
sharing the physical server with
multiple customers that is generally a
good thing because you are paying a
fraction of the server cost you don't to
buy that server outright you are still
gonna be overpaying for under
underutilized the under utilization of a
virtual machine because it sells that
issue of wasted space because you have
to choose a particular size of virtual
machine it's not going to be perfectly
fit for your application you are going
to be limited by your guest operating
system so whatever OS that you've chosen
that's what you get so that's that's
what you have there if you want to run
multiple apps on a single virtual
machine they can still result in
conflict resource sharing but now
customers that are isolate from you
aren't going to conflict with you so you
can run you could run if you had three
option could run them as three virtual
machines so you're not have that issue
but if they're on the same VM you still
have that issue so there you go that is
virtual machines and we'll move on to
containers hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and we are looking at the
concept of containers and so this takes
it a step further where we have virtual
machines and we're running multiple
containers so we're even
we're further subdividing the way that
we run our applications and the
technology that is used to run
containers with within a VM or on a
physical server is called doc docker
Damon if you're using docker for cleaner
ization that's the most common one but
that's gonna let you run multiple
containers and you can maximize the
utility of the available capacity so
this is extremely more cost effective
right so the available space is always
there for you to launch more servers
within or you can or you can expand the
usage for your app to take
that available space your containers
share the same underlying OS so the
containers are more efficient than
multiple of VMs but the great thing is
is that you can have different OSS so
the idea is that each container can
technically be running a different oh s
and so now you have a lot more
flexibility it doesn't seem like you
could improve upon this further but we
will we move over to functions so now
we're going to take a look at the
evolution of computing for functions and
I bet you didn't believe it but we
subdivided to even further and so we've
taken our applications that were running
containers and we broke up the apps into
little pieces of code called functions
and now we even have more or better
utility of our compute so we have a
managed VM running managed containers so
we don't have to worry about the
containers you can figure them ourselves
functions are usually taken care of this
is known as service compute because you
don't setup anything you just put your
code online and it just works you might
choose the memory and the duration that
you need to utilize and that's all you
pay for you're only responsible for your
code and data and nothing else and it's
extremely extremely cost effective right
because you are just paying for that
individual function to run and all that
underutilized spaces is the the problem
of the cloud service provider it's not
your issue the only downside is that
there is a concept called cold starts
meaning that when you launch a function
or service or a service code it
generally has to provision a server
because the the the cloud service
provider doesn't to be running servers
when they don't they don't they aren't
being utilized so you might experience a
cold start where you're waiting for a
server to start before your code will
execute but there's definitely ways
around that so there you go that is the
evolution of compute
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at regions and
geographies for Asher so a region is a
grouping of multiple data centers and
for Asher they call their data centers
availability zones azor has 58 regions
available across 140 countries one thing
as your likes to promote is that they
have the most regions out of all cloud
service providers then we have something
what we call a geography so geography is
a discrete market of two or more regions
that preserve data residency and
compliance boundaries and the
geographies that are available for Azure
we have the United States then there's a
j''r government US this is a geography
that's only for the US government
so regular citizens cannot use it then
you have Canada that's where I'm from
Brazil and Mexico and I just want to
emphasize that data residency and
compliance boundaries for geography and
I just want to give you an example so
imagine you live in Canada and you and
you work for Canadian company and you
want to guarantee that the data will
remain within Canada for whatever
government regular regulatory reasons so
then you'd want to use the candidate as
your geography because that data would
never leave Canadian soil so that's the
case there and I just want to give you
kind of a visual example so on the left
hand side we have two regions we have US
East one and we have the Europe Norway
East region and in those regions I'm not
showing it here because I don't want to
make it too complicated but there would
be availability zones and we could
launch resources so we have some servers
virtual machines those are the images
you see within the regions and generally
the way regions work in Azure is that
when you go to launch a resource you
choose the region at that time of
creation so if you're launching a
virtual machine it's gonna give you an
option to choose a region and you just
choose from that list so yeah there you
go
so I just made my way over to Azure so I
just typed in Azure global
infrastructure because I just wanted to
show you the big map of all the regions
whereas ER is available all throughout
the world because sometimes it's nice to
look here see we can see we have stuff
down in Australia we have regions in
Africa we have a region in South America
we have a lot in North America we have a
lot in Western Europe and then we have
some in Asia here so we have Japan China
all over the place so you know if you
want to look a little bit more into that
there's a lot of good information here
on the global infrastructure pages but
that's about it I just wanted to show
you that world map so now we're looking
at paired regions so each region is
paired with another region 300 miles
away and the reason why Asher does this
is so that if one region is being
updated then the other one is still
available meaning that if you're running
if you're planning to make sure that you
never have downtime you can put your
resources in that paired region and
you're gonna have higher availability so
some Azure services rely on paired
regions for disaster recovery so when
you turn those services on they're
automatically going to launch in that
pair to region one service which would
help you leverage your paired region
would be a service called asier
while it's a feature of storage but it's
called a Georgio redundant storage so to
replicate your data to secondary region
automatically insuring the data is
durable even in the event the primary
region is it recoverable and just to
give you an example of a paired region
so let's say we're talking about Canada
so with Canada you'd have Canada Central
and then it's paired region is Canada
East for North America and where we say
North America we really talking about
the United States it's East US region
paired with the West US region and then
for Germany you have Germany Central and
germ Germany northeast so it gives you
idea how far away they are 300 miles
it's quite a distance but there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam fro
and we are looking at region types and
service availability for Azure and what
I want you to know about service
availability regarding regions is that
not all cloud services are available in
every single region and there's
infrastructure reasons as to why and
there's compliance reasons as to why so
Azure has two types of regions they have
recommended regions these are regions
that provide the broadest range of
service capabilities what that means is
that the majority of services are going
to be available in this region and this
recommended region is designed to
support availability zones then you have
alternate regions and these are regions
that extends Asher's footprint within a
data residency boundary where
recommended region also exists but
they're not designed to support
availability zones that doesn't mean you
can't launch resources within them it
just means that when you go to lots of
resource you're not going to choose an
availability zone and these regions are
labeled as other when you're in the
azure portal now let's talk about
general availability so general
availability abbreviated to GA is when a
service is considered ready to be used
publicly by everyone so if you have a
service or product and it was in beta
and now you're ready to sell to people
that means that it's GA but it's a but
just because it's where you sell it
there's also the the conversation around
whether it's actually available to use
and that's going to be determined based
on the category that the azure cloud
service is in and so as your categorizes
three different types of availability
for services and the first one is
foundational so a cloud service that is
foundational is going to be available
immediately in a recommended and
alternate regions when it goes GA or at
least in twelve months of the time that
it was announced then you have
mainstream so these are cloud services
that will become immediately available
in a recommended region or in twelve
months when it goes GA but for the
alternate region it may become available
based on the customer demand and then
the last one is specialized so cloud
services are in this category will
become available in recommended or
alternate regions base
customer demand so hopefully that clears
up service availability and reagent
types
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at special regions
for Azure so Azure has specialized
regions to meet compliance or legal
reasons because they might know what
they might want to work with specific
governments of and to meet those
requirements they basically give them
their own region and so the first our
list is the US and we have three regions
that we know about so we have the US
Department of Defense Central the US
government Virginia region the US
government of Iowa region and then we
have an additional three that we just
don't know about it because they're in
secret locations so maybe they're for
area 51 we don't know and so the reason
why they have these special regions is
that if you just want to do business
with the government they need these kind
of regulations then on the other side we
have China and so they have a region in
China East and China north and these
regions are available through a unique
partnership between Microsoft and 21v
Annette and so Microsoft does not
directly maintain these data centers but
they work with 21 via net to give you
accessibility to these regions and
probably to operate these regions you'd
probably be assistant of these countries
and you'd also be an employee of the
government so it's not going to be for
citizens to use but there you go
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at availability zones
for Azure and so availability zones
abbreviated to short for AZ and you'll
hear me using that abbreviation a lot in
this course and you should learn to
remember that as well it's a physical
location made up of one or more data
center and so a data center is a secured
building that contains hundreds of
thousands of computers and if you want a
little visual here is the inside of a
data center and there's a technician
working on a rack of servers and there's
a dog in the data center you should
definitely never have a dog in your data
center you'll probably hear me refer to
available available zones as a data
center because it's the easiest way to
think of it but it actually can be more
than one data center
now a region will generally contain
three availability zones I say generally
here because there are cases where there
are less than three but there's actually
very specific reasons as to having
exactly three availability zones data
centers within a region will be isolate
from each other so they'll be in
different buildings but they will be
close enough to provide low latency and
that low latency would probably be in
the sub milliseconds I don't know what
it is Roger but that's generally how it
would be designed because you wanted to
feel like you're it's on the same
network it's common practice to run
workloads in at least three AZ's and
that's why I was saying that earlier
that's important to ensure services
remain available in the case one or two
data centers fail fail and this is
called high availability and we'll
definitely cover this concept again in
this course just to give you a bit of a
visual on the left-hand side what we
have is a region called US East one and
we have multiple availability zones as
you're just labels them one two and
three and so when you go to launch a
resource if you look on the right hand
side you choose your region so we are
choosing us
East us then we were saying we're going
to use the availability zone and then we
choose which one we want to launch it
into so if we if we choose to it's gonna
go into availability zone - that doesn't
mean we're gonna launch two instances it
just means availability zone - so there
you go hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and we are looking at AZ
supported regions for Azure and so not
every region has support for
availability zones and we touched on
this in the region section but we'll
touch on it here again so we know that
there are regions called alternate or
others and these do not have
availability zones whatsoever then you
have recommended regions and these are
supposed to have 3a Z's the reason why
they might not have them is because it's
a newer region and azure is promising to
add more regions within 12 months or
whatever time period that they say but
generally what you want to do is when
you have cloud resources you want to
launch them where they have at least
three AZ so which regions actually have
3a Z's and that is central US East us -
West us - West Europe France Central
North
Northern Europe Southeast Asia so that
is where you generally want to run your
workloads now what does it look like
when you try to go launch a resource and
they and you choose a region that
doesn't have and available there's no
what's that gonna look like well it's
gonna look like this so you're gonna
Vale ability zones gonna be blanked out
and you'll have to choose no
infrastructure redundancy required and
so that would be the example for Brazil
south where it's just there are there is
a single AZ but it's described as not
having an easy so you just don't choose
it in the interface so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we were looking at fault and update
domains so an availability zone in an
azure region is a combination of a fault
domain and an update domain so a fault
domain is a logical grouping of hardware
to avoid a single point of failure
within an AZ and so basically it's a
group of virtual machines that share a
common power source and network switch
the reason why Azure does this is that
so if part of the data center fails then
other servers won't be taking down with
it so let's say there's a fire within
the data center in one particular region
it won't affect other hardware that is
running then you have update domains and
so update domains is when azor needs to
apply updates to the underlying hardware
and software but the thing is is that
because as you're updating them it takes
these machines offline so the idea is
that if you run your workloads in
another like another domain and they
update domain nutin neither domain will
be updated the exact same time and that
way you won't have downtime because of
updates and so the way fault domains and
update domains work is that you use
availability sets so availability sets
is a logical grouping that you can use
an azure to ensure that your VMs you
place and availability set are in
different fault update domains to avoid
a downtime and just to really help with
that visual here what I'm going to do is
just show you this here so each virtual
machine and availability set is assigned
a fault domain and update domain and so
what you're looking at here is you see
those grey boxes those are rack
in your data center iraq is just like
it's like a closet for servers and all
those servers sit on top of each other
and so each of those servers in that is
where your virtual machine might be
deployed so if you are deployed if you
have a server and it's deployed in fault
domain 0 and fault domain 1 it could be
in any of the the servers on that rack
but then update domains you just might
have very particular servers in that
rack that are those update domains so
hopefully that makes that a bit clearer
a little bit confusing but just remember
the constantly behind fault domains and
update domains and just to give you a
visual of what it would look like in the
azure portal if you go ahead and create
availability set you would name it so
here I call it production and you would
choose the fault domains and you would
choose the update domains and so I
believe that what you're doing there is
that you're choosing the amount of
domains that you want your your virtual
machines to be distributed across and I
keep on saying virtual machine that's
your server ok
so if you say 2 fault domains that means
that when you launch two servers and you
put them into that availability set
they're gonna be crossed to fault two
different fault domains and if you
launch five servers and your update
domains is at five that means it's gonna
be across five different servers that
are isolated from each other so
hopefully that makes sense but that's
Fault and update domains so I quickly
just wanted to show you the fault and
update domains that are in Azure here so
the idea is if you're launching a
virtual machine and you want to control
the availability set what you can do is
you can go to down to here where we have
availability options we're going to drop
it down and choose availability set and
then we don't have an availability set
so I'm going to go ahead and create one
if I just click there and so when we
create a set we'd say you know
production set and so we have these two
these two dialogues here and so what
what it is is when you say there's three
a fault domains that means that if you
were to launch three VMs and you put
them all into this availability set
it'll be spread across
three different racks so that if a rack
goes out to other racks are operational
and so your service will remain
available and then down below it's the
same thing on a rack there might be
multiple machines and certain machines
will will be will be scheduled for
updates but they won't all be update at
the same time so if you're saying this
you'll say spread it across five
machines and that's all there really is
to it so I just wanted to show you where
that was when you actually launch it for
a virtual machine hey this is Andrew
Brown from exam pro and we are looking
at Korean ourselves their own Azure
account so that we can get some hands-on
experience with Azure so what I've done
here is I've gone to Azure Microsoft
comm and that's what I want you to do as
well and then when you're here just look
for free account they have it everywhere
so they have it here and they have it
here and I bet you could even get it
through sign-in well what I'm going to
do is just click free account here in
the top right corner and then when I'm
here we're gonna have another start free
button so we'll go ahead and click that
and so now we have to login with our
Microsoft account or if you don't have
one we'll create one I'm going to create
a new one and I create an email just for
this tutorial here it's called a shirt
exam Pro CO and I'm going to need to set
a password so I'm just going to go off
screen and generate myself a password
great so I just generated myself out a
very strong pass or I'm just going to
paste that in there
and I'm going to proceed forward and so
the next thing it's going to ask is just
going to send me an email to my email
there and I'm gonna have to enter a
verification code so I'll be back here
in a moment to show you that code okay
so I went ahead and checked my email and
immediately I received a verification
code so mine is six five nine nine
yours is going to be different so I'm
just going to go ahead and enter mine in
here so it was six five nine nine and
I'm good I don't need any tips or offers
and then we'll proceed to next and so
now before we proceed we have to
complete this challenge here so let's
give it a go so we have x + 5 www
q alright and so after waiting a little
bit for this page to load we have some
information so we have to fill in our
about you so our country your first name
last name email phone number identity
verification by phone identity
verification by card oh wow they have a
lot of steps here and so we will make
our way through here so now I'm just
going to go ahead and fill this
information and I'll see you here in a
moment so I just filled in the about you
section here and so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna just proceed to next and so
now it's going to ask me to verify my
identity by phone so I want a text
message so I'm gonna click the text me
button and so I'm just going to check my
phone for that verification code and so
I've received the text message for the
verification code I'm just going to go
ahead and enter that in so it might
happens to be three five one zero three
three your codes gonna be different from
my code I'm going to go ahead and verify
that code alright and so it looks like
it's going to ask us to identify our
verification by card so we're just
waiting for something to load here and
so what we're gonna have to do is we're
gonna have to enter in credit card
information so we'll just go ahead here
and fill that in so I have gone ahead
and filled in my credit card information
I'm just gonna proceed to next great and
so now that it's been verified I can go
ahead and just go ahead and click on
their agreements so I'm going to say I
agree to the subscription and the second
one I do not have to check box let's if
I want to get tips and offers but the
first one I'll definitely check box
because we have to and we'll go ahead
and sign up great and so now we are here
it looks like we are ready I guess you
could schedule a live demo which seems a
very generous of Azure but I'm just
going to go ahead and proceed to the
portal and so here we are we made it
into Microsoft Azure and what you're
looking at right now is the portal it's
telling me I have two hundred sixty
dollars worth of credits if you're
wondering why it's higher than yours or
lower than yours
notice that it's in Canadian dollars so
I believe that it's 200 USD and when
that's converting my currency it's a bit
higher and so it might be different for
for you but there you go that's all we
had to do to create the account and now
we can actually start learning other
things in Azure hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam pro and I just wanted to
quickly show you that you can change the
experience of your Azure portal if you
just go all the way up here and click
the COG you can switch the default view
from home or dashboard you can change
the fly out here so it's docked which is
a lot easier when you're navigating
stuff all the time if you're choose if
you want to change your theme you can go
do a dark mode here or even you can do a
high contrast so very old-school but
very easy on the eye so just wanted to
make that aware to you because you may
feel that you want to change your
experience right off the bat so there
you go hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and we are looking at Azure
computing services starting with Azure
virtual machines so virtual machine is
going to be the most common type of
compute whenever you're launching a
server I would just think of a virtual
machine and your virtual machines could
either be running Windows or the Linux
operating system now the great thing
with virtual machines is you get a lot
of configurations so you can choose your
OS the amount of memory the mental CPU
you can attach storage to it the thing
here is that because it's a virtual
machine the the hardware shared with
other customers you can dedicate it but
generally it's shared and then you get a
virtual computer so it seems like you
have like 100% of the resource ok then
we have as your container instances so
this I would describe as docker as a
service you can run containerized apps
probably runs docker in both windows
containers because I believe Windows has
containers as well but runs containerize
a pleasure without provisioning servers
or VM so makes that a lot easier for you
the next sound is very similar which is
called asier kubernetes service so it's
kubernetes as a service easy to deploy
manage and scale containerized
applications so the idea here is that
kubernetes is just another way of
working with containers but it's using
an open source
urban Eddie's has basically become the
de-facto for containers and so we've
seen all the cloud providers try to make
their own service or orchestration
service but kubernetes kind of won out
so you'll see it on all platforms the
next one is as your service fabric this
one can be a bit confusing because it's
described as many things but I'm going
to describe you here as a Tier one
enterprise container as a service
application or a cloud service so it's
for distributed system platforms it runs
on on the azure cloud or on-premise and
the way they described is easy to
package deploy and manage scalable and
reliable micro services and any time you
hear the word micro services think of
also containers so with Azure Container
instances and azure kubernetes services
that's where you'd also run micro
services then we have as your functions
so this would be event-driven serverless
compute anytime remote servers compute
we're use the time about service
functions which are little bytes of code
that you can just upload and it just
works you don't have to think about the
servers or provision anything and you
only pay for the time to that code run
so service functions generally run for a
very short duration and as soon as
they're done those underlying servers
are shutting off and the last our list
here is as your batch so you can plan
scheduled and execute your batch compute
workloads across 100 plus jobs in
parallel when I say jobs here it's just
the code that you want to run you can
use spot VMs spot beams might not be out
at the time of this but it will be in
the future but generally it's known as
low priority VMs but the idea here is
that there are virtual machines that are
being underutilized and so azure is
allowing you to rent them at a more
cost-effective cost and so if you're
doing a lot of scientific compute or
other things and it doesn't matter if
these services get interrupted and you
want to use those low priority VMs that
is a great way to save and that is the
computing services
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Azure storage
services starting with Azure blob
storage so I would describe this as
objects serverless storage so if you
ever heard of object storage or servlets
storage this is gonna make sense to you
so you're able to store very large files
and enlarge amounts of unstructured
files and the idea here is that you pay
for only what you store
it's basically unlimited storage you
don't have to resize the volumes you
don't have to worry about file system
protocols you just upload files and
that's why it's considered serverless
storage then we're gonna move on to
Azure dis storage this is the most
common type of storage you'll encounter
so you can describe it as a virtual
volume so you're just choosing either an
SSD or HDD so it's basically a hard
drive in the cloud
it has encryption by default and it's
attached to virtual machines so anytime
you're spinning up a virtual machine
it's probably spinning up also as you're
de storage attached to it then you have
as your file storage so this is a shared
volume that you can access and manage
like a file server so it's going to use
protocols such as SMB the reason you'd
want this is that let's say you had
multiple virtual machines multiple
servers and you wanted them to all share
the same hard drive that's what you'd
use it for or if you need to have users
access it using those protocols that's
another way of doing that then you have
as your Kube storage now I put an
asterisk in front of it because this is
just a weirdly named service because
this is really for a messaging queue
this is actually for application
integration by Alyssa here because they
put the word storage on so I just think
it's poorly named and even the way to
describe it is is just makes you think
it's storage but it's a data store for
queueing and reliably delivering
messages between applications so it's
just integrating two applications
together passing messages along another
one that's confusing is as your table
storage I would put this in the database
categories and it's a no SQL database
and specifically it's a wide column no
aschool database as they describe it's a
no scroll store that hosts
structured data independent from any
schema so just be aware of those two
they're just very poorly worded then you
have as your data box and also it's
upgraded version the Azure data box
heavy this is a rugged briefcase
computer and storage designed to move
terabytes or petabytes of data so
imagine somebody shows up your door with
this this tower that's a computer and
you plug in your USB or whatever
whatever you want and you transfer all
your files locally on your on-premise
data center and then they they ship it
because it's faster to ship the data on
a physical piece of device and it is to
send it over the Internet that's what as
your data box is and then we have as
your archive storage so this is long
term cold storage for when you need to
hold on to files for years but you want
the cheapest storage options if you have
lots of data and it's not it's not doing
anything you definitely want to be
opening on the cheapest possible storage
devices cheap meaning doesn't mean that
they're not reliable it just means that
they're not active the disks are not
actively spinning nobody's accessing the
data on those hard drives the last one
is as your as your data Lake storage and
so this is a centralized repository that
allows you to store all structured and
unstructured data at any scale when
you're working with big data from
multiple different sources it need to be
in one place that is the service for you
and so that is the Azure storage
services hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we were looking at Azure
database services starting the top of
her list is Azure cosmos DB this is a
fully managed no sculled database it's
designed for scale with guarantee of
99.999% availability as your love's
talking about this database it's their
flagship database because it works at
incredible scale and an incredible
performance so whenever you're thinking
about like like super large databases
think of Azure cosmos DB next on our
list is Azure SQL database and even
though it doesn't have it in its name
this is for the MS SQL engine so if
you're running Microsoft SQL you're
gonna want to use this it's fully
managed with Auto scale integrity
integral intelligence robust security
says a lot of great features built
around this for msl SQL databases now if
you're not using ms SQL and you're using
something like my school Postgres or
Mario DB they have Azure database so
it's fully managed and scalable with
high availability and security then you
have SQL Server on VMs again it doesn't
have its name but it's Microsoft SQL
engine ok any time
it says SQL servers just assume that
it's the Microsoft flavor of SQL and and
the idea for this one is that if you
already have SQL servers running
on-premise within your data center and
you want to move them onto a sure this
is where you'd use a lift and shift so
it takes those virtual machines and
directly moves them on to the cloud you
don't get all the functionality that you
would with Azure SQL database but it's
the easiest way to get on to the cloud
then you have as your synapsis analytics
previously known as as your SQL data
warehouse it's because they added an
analytics component to it but it's a
fully managed data warehouse with
integrity Integra security at every
level scale at no extra cost then you
have Azure database migration service so
migrate your databases to the cloud with
no application code changes so there's
that service then you have as your cash
for Redis so if you need an in-memory
cache that is using the open source
Redis you can use that and last on our
list is as your table storage we
mentioned this in these storage services
but to me this is a database it's not a
storage service even though it's named
as such so why call them Noel database
analyst cool store that hosts
unstructured data independent of any
schema so there you go that's the Azure
database services
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we were looking at application
integration services on Azure now I
didn't have room on the slide for this
but just to tell you what application
integration is these are services that
are designed to help apps or services
talk to each other so it's basically the
glue of services the first on our list
here is azor notifications hub this is
using publisher subscription technology
underneath and this is for sending push
notifications to any platform from any
back-end next we have as your API apps
so this is essentially an API gateway so
you can quickly build and consume api's
in the cloud and then those api's will
have API endpoints and you can route
them to Azure services or maybe
functions or containers but it's a way
of building an API in the cloud then you
have Azure service bus and as the name
implies it is a service bus so reliable
cloud messaging as a service mas and
simple hybrid integration I know that's
not very clear that is the language that
Microsoft uses to describe it but just
what you need to know is that it is a
service bus then you have as your stream
analytics
so this is service real-time analytics
remember that world word real-time and
think of this service from the cloud to
the edge then you have as your logic
apps so you can schedule automate
orchestrate tasks business processes and
workflows and it integrates with
Enterprise SAS and enterprise
applications then you have as your API
management this can be confusing because
we have another service called as your
API apps I don't know what we would
generally call this service they say
it's a hybrid multi cloud management
platform for api's across all
environments
whatever that means but the when I
looked at it what it does is you can put
this in front of an existing API to add
additional functionality so if you have
an API you put it in front of it and
it's a basically a proxy to your API and
you get all this additional stuff then
last night our list is Azure q storage
we saw this in our storage service
sections and I had said that I don't
really consider this a storage service I
consider it an application integration
service and this is a messaging queue so
it's a datastore
queuing and reliably delivering messages
between applications so there you go
that is the application integration
services on Azure hey this is Andrew
Brown from exam pro and we were looking
at developer and mobile tools that are
commonly used with Azure so first time
list is azure signal are service and
this is a real-time messaging service
not to be confused with Asher's
notification service this is for easily
adding real-time web functionality to
applications so have you ever heard of
pusher it's just like pusher so that is
the equivalent there the next we have is
as your app service so easy to use
service for deploying and scaling web
applications with net no GS Java Python
and PHP I'm a bit sad I don't see Ruby
in there but what are you gonna do so
it's for developers want to focus on
building their web apps and not worry
about the underlying infrastructure so
if you've ever used Heroku think of it
like that but for a sure next you have a
visual studio and visual studio is a
code editor it's it it's basically an
IDE an integrated development
development environment design for
creating powerful scalable applications
for Azure you might have heard of Visual
Studio code which is similar but
different but I just wanted to make
mention of Visual Studio here then you
have xamarin I think I'm pronouncing it
right and it's a mobile app framework
it's for creating powerful and scalable
native mobile apps and dotnet and Azure
and yeah so that is the developer in
mobile tools for Azure
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we were looking at Azure DevOps
services so Azure DevOps is really just
an umbrella service for a bunch of
modern dev services and we'll jump into
them right away first being as your
boards if you've ever used a Kanban
board that is what Azure boards is and
if you ever use github projects
it literally is that because Asscher and
github are owned by the same company
Microsoft and so they brought over that
technology to Azure so deliver value to
your users faster using proven agile
tools to plan track and discuss work
across your teams then you have Azure
pipeline so build test and deploy CI a
CD that works with any language platform
and cloud connect to github or any other
get provider and deploy continuously so
if you need automatic deployments that's
what as your pipelines is for then you
have as your repos and this is exactly
like github repos so get unlimited code
cloud hosted private git repos and
collaborate to build better code with
pull requests and advanced file
management I really mean it's just like
github repos because it's just that
technology moved over to Azure then you
have as your test plan so test and ship
with confidence using manual and
exploratory testing tools so this is
just a way of setting up tests so if you
ever used like was it called Cypress or
any other like or any other testing
tools it's just built into a sharable
it'll open up a browser and a literally
test your application and make sure it
works as expected then you have as your
artifacts so create hosts and share
packages with your team so this is just
package management but specifically for
CI CD pipelines so the CI CD pipelines
they have to set up these servers and
you have to have pre installed packages
that's just going to make it a lot
easier for you lasses as your dev test
labs so this is just an easy way to
create dev test environments for your
developers and that is the azure devops
services
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we were looking at as your resource
manager and just to understand the
service when you understand what
infrastructure as code is so also
preview does IAC this is the process of
managing and provisioning computer data
centers through machine readable
definition files rather than physical
hardware configurations or interactive
configuration tools if that is
complicated all it means is that we're
using scripts we're using scripts to
setup the services like vm's or
databases or storage so you don't the
manually go through the interface or you
can give that script to another team or
company and they can set up the exact
same setup you have within seconds so
the the info section airs code service
for Azure is called a Juris resource
manager or arm for short and allows you
to programmatically create Azure
resources via JSON template I'm just
going to show you what that template
looks like so you would make this
template and it'll allow you to launch a
virtual machine okay so instead of going
through the interface and clicking and
doing a bunch of stuff you just define
all the stuff you want to even chase on
this is a very short version of it
there's definitely a lot more
configuration that would be required but
here this would be a very easy way to
set up a virtual machine using code hey
this is Andrew Brown from exam pro and
we're looking at a short QuickStart
templates so Azure QuickStart templates
is a library of pre-made arm templates
provided by the community partners to
help you quickly launch new projects for
a variety of stack scenarios so the last
slide we just talked about as your
resource manager where it's just a
template - or a JSON file to quickly set
up resources well that is taking that
file and just sharing with other people
right but it's shared through actual
vendors okay so you could go to the
azure QuickStart and let's say you
wanted to deploy a django app and I
think it's like also those vendors and
also community contributed scripts so if
you want to deploy an azure or sorry a
django app you could use that
Quick Start if you wanted to deploy
Ubuntu with a docker engine you could
use that script if you wanted a CI CD
continue eyes app with docker enterprise
Jenkins you could use that script and if
you wanted a web app that was running
Linux with Postgres you could use that
script so it's just a quick way of
getting started
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at as your virtual
networks also known as v-net and the
concept of subnets so a virtual network
and as we said it stands for v-net is a
logically isolated section of the azure
network where you launch and your azure
resources and when you create a virtual
network you have to define a certain
amount of IP addresses that you're going
to use which we call a cider range we'll
come back to that in a moment but here
is a graphical representation of your
a/v net so here we have the azure
network and then within that we have a
region so US East one and then we would
create our virtual network so that we
can launch our azure resources within
and in there we have two subnets a
public one a private one and then in the
public one we have a virtual machine the
private one we have a database and the
and the in the public one it's actually
it can actually have access to the
Internet where's the private one it does
not so not all services require a v-net
but most do so because you just have to
put your resources somewhere and they
have to go into a virtual network which
are associated with an IP address
whether it's public or private and then
there's other network controls that are
involved so now let's take a look at the
cider range so cider range I said is
just an allocation of IP addresses that
you are gonna use in your virtual
network all I want you to know is that
see where says 10.0.0.0 that's the name
of our network but we have that 4/16
that is the cider range and the lower
the number the more IP addresses you get
I'm not going to get into the math in
this video it's not necessary but just
understand that 46:15 is a very big
number and that's the amount of IP
addresses that we can launch so we could
essentially launch 65,000 servers within
this virtual network and so we can
subdivide
our virtual network into subnets so it's
a logical partition of an IP network
into smaller network segments so that's
what you're doing you're breaking up it
into smaller IP ranges and when you
create a sudden that's they have to be
smaller so you have to admit you have to
define a side arrange for those as well
but they have to be smaller than the V
net remember I said the higher the
number the lower it is so when you have
forward slash 24 that's just saying 256
IP addresses all right and one more
thing is I want to note is that we have
things called public subnets and private
sudden it's a public subnets reach the
internet private subnets do not so when
you have sensitive things like your
database you don't want that to be in a
public subnet but a web app which
generally has traffic coming from it
from the internet that's okay
all right and that's all we need to know
here hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
pro and we are looking at the cloud NATO
networking services now these networking
services aren't super super important
for the exam but I like to go through
them generally it would make an
architectural diagram for this but it's
just a bit too complicated so I thought
we'll just go through and list them so
the first is as your DNS and we do
describe the service later in the course
here but this provides an ultra-fast DNS
response as an ultra high domain
availability so if you have a domain
name and you just want it to be managed
by a j''r you can associate it with
Azure DNS then you have as your virtual
network we talked about this prior but
we'll talk about it again
short for v-net a logical isolated
section of your Azure network for
customers to launch Azure resources
within then you have as your load
balancer and as the name implies it is a
load balancer but this one is at level 4
transport so it doesn't really
understand requests like what a web
application would send it's more lower
level and so that's what that is then
you have as your application gateway and
this is an HTTP load balancer so it does
understand like requests coming from a
web server and what you can do with it
is you can actually route based on HP
requests to specific services but also
you can apply a Web Application Firewall
because it isn't
application load bouncer that's why you
can ply that web application firewall
which is a separate service then you
have network security groups so this is
a way of protecting your subnets so it's
a virtual firewall around your subnets
where you can say allow these allow
these ports to be open and and from who
and and and such so there you go that's
the cloud native networking services and
the reason why their cloud native
networking is because you wouldn't use
these with enterprise Iran or or in
hybrid models it's just what you
normally use and most Serbs would be
using all these clout these networking
services so next we have enterprise or
hybrid networking services so this is
when you're using networking that is
going to bridge on Prem to the cloud so
the first is as your front door so this
is a scalable and secure entry point for
fast delivery of your global
applications such as making sure you
have a secure entry point into Azure
from outside then you have as your
Express route you want to remember this
one definitely for the exam it probably
will show up as a question this is a
connection between your on-premise to
Azure cloud and it between 50 megabytes
per second to 10 gigabytes per second
I'm pretty sure it's also secure but the
point is is that if you need a super
super fast connection from your on-prem
datacenter to a sure you'd use this
service Express route remember it's
going to be on your exam then you have
virtual LAN so a network service that
brings many networking security routing
functionality together to provide a
single Operations operational interface
I know that sounds complicated but a win
is just a way of making networking
easier by creating like a hub spoke
model then you have Azure connection so
a VPN connection securely connects to as
your local networks via IPSec so that's
just a way of creating a secure
connection with Azure then you have
virtual network gateway a site-to-site
VPN connection between Azure virtual
network and your local network so this
is just a way of connecting with Azure
so there you go that is
the networking services hey this is
Angie Brown from exam Pro and we are
looking at Azure traffic manager so this
service operates at the DNS layer to
quickly and efficiently direct incoming
DNS requests based on the routing method
of your choice so what you do is you
choose a routing method so we got
performance weighted priority geography
or graphic multi-value subnet and you'd
be able to reroute your traffic so you
could rub traffic to service
geographically nearby to reduce latency
failover to redundant systems in case
primary systems become unhealthy our
route to random virtual machines to
simulate a be testing I think like the
best use cases fail overs for D at the
DNS level right that's a great one and
just a visual example here imagine we
had exam proko and we had a production
server and a beta server and we only
wanted 20% of our users to see the beta
server so we could use I guess we've
used waited there and we'd say 80% on
prod 20% there and that's how that would
work so you go that's a sure traffic
manager hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and we were looking at a sure
DNS I told you we would come back to
this one because we're on the networking
slides I just did not describe this in
detail so as your DNS allows you to host
your domain names on Azure you can
create DNS zones and manage your DNS
records so if you wanted to add a record
like let's say we had exam Pro and it
was being managed by DNS as your DNS we
could add beta as a subdomain and we
could use alias to route that to a load
balancer or virtual machine and then
that would go into our list of Records
one thing that is interesting it's kind
of a like a downer which is Asscher dns
does not allow you to purchase domain so
it only gives you the ability to manage
DNS records some other cloud providers
they allow you to purchase and manage
but only as your dns does not at this
time maybe in the future
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at Azure a load
balancer we had only mentioned this
briefly in the networking services slide
and so we'll look at it more here so as
your load balancer is used for evenly
distributing incoming network traffic
across a group of back-end resources or
servers as your load bouncer operates on
the OSI layer 4 that's the transport
layer so it doesn't understand HTTP
requests it's just sending packets back
and forth so here is a graphical
representation so imagine you have the
internet and somehow it's making its way
to the load balancer if the load
balancer is going to do is it's going to
distribute that amongst your virtual
machines virtual machines being your
servers and the great thing is is that
you can have virtual machines in
different availability zones and the
load balancer can distribute it to to
those and that's how we get high
availability ok and now with as your
load balancer you can create both a
public load balancer so that's incoming
traffic from the Internet to public
facing servers so servers that have a
public IP address with internal or
easier way to describe would be a
private load balancer so incoming
internal network traffic to private
facing servers so private IP addresses
so there you go hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam pro and we are looking at
scale sets and so this allows you to
group identical virtual machines and
automatically increase or decrease the
amount of servers based on the change in
CPU memory disk network performance or
on a predefined schedule so when we talk
about elasticity we're talking about
using scale sets the ability to
automatically increase or decrease the
amount of servers so here is a visual
representation imagine you have internet
traffic and it hits that load balancer
and then we determined that the current
load on the existing server is greater
than 80 percent CPU utilization it's
gonna need some extra servers and so
what happens is the
skill set decides okay we're going to
have to add one or two more servers and
when that cpu usage goes below 80% then
it says okay we don't need those servers
anymore get rid of them okay so that is
scale sets hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and we're looking at IOT
services on Azure and so before we get
into it what is IOT so IOT stands for
Internet of Things so a network of
internet connected objects usually
Hardware able to connect and exchange
data so here is a graphical
representation of IOT devices maybe you
recognize some but let's just go through
a quick list of things that could be IOT
devices so you have smart bulb so maybe
there's light bulbs in your house that
are controlled by the internet smart
fridges who doesn't want one of those
smart light switches narrow band or
wideband hardware this is just a way of
connecting the Internet it's just like
it's kind of like Wi-Fi then you have
security cameras then you have voice
command speakers so think of like Alexa
then you might have temperature pressure
or humidity sensors if you're in the
farming industry you can you you can
leverage leverage IOT devices for that
maybe you have drones maybe you have
phones that could be a 92 device and
even buttons so AWS had these things
called eight of us or - buttons they
weren't popular but the idea was you
could like press a button and like
purchase something so like if you always
had to get like soap for your washer you
could have that button right on your
washer but let's actually talk about the
IOT services here so the first one here
is IOT Central's this allows you to
connect your IOT devices to the cloud
then you have IOT hub so this is this
enables highly secured and reliable
communications between your IOT
applications and devices it manages then
you have IOT edge it is a fully managed
service built on the azure IOT hub it
allows you allows data processing and
analysts near the IOT devices so this is
really edge computing I really should
have highlighted that for you but this
is where you are able to offload your
Compu from the cloud to local computing
hardware such as IOT devices phones or
home computers so it's just a way of
saving money or utilizing your low
network for compute then you have
Windows 10 IOT core services so this is
a cloud services subscription that
provides the essential services need to
commercialize a device on Windows IOT or
10 IOT core so basically its long-term
OS support and services to manage device
updates and assess device health alright
so there you go that's your IOT services
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we were looking at big data and
analytic services on Azure so Before we
jump into it let's talk about what is
Big Data so it is a term used to
describe massive volumes of structured
and unstructured data that it's so large
it is difficult to move in process using
traditional database and software
techniques so we need special services
just to handle them the first on our
list here is as your synapses analytics
formerly known as SQL data warehouse so
it just enterprise data warehousing and
big data analytics so it's intended to
run SQL queries against large databases
to generate things such as reporting
then you have HD insite HD is short for
Hadoop but anyway it runs open source
analytic software such as Hadoop Kafka
and SPARC I imagine it was called HD
insight because it only supported Hadoop
and then they added additional services
but that's just what it's called then
you have Azure data bricks so we have a
patchy spark based analytics platform
optimized for Microsoft Azure cloud
service platforms so third-party data
bricks cloud services supported with a
sure so data bricks was made by the
creators of spark and yes of course you
can run spark on HD insight but data
bricks is its own cloud service provider
and azure partnered up with them so that
you can use it within the azure platform
then you have data like analytics so an
on-demand analytics job service that
simplifies
Big Data and we saw what data leaks were
when we looked at storage services but
we'll describe them here just in a
different a little bit different way a
de Lake is a storage repository that
holds a vast amount of raw data in its
native format until it is needed so
there you go that is the big data and
analytic services we need to know
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at artificial
intelligence and machine learning
services on Azure so a great way of
describing that is to always have this
graphic here where we has it's kind of
like an onion thing where each is
dependent on the other and we'll start
with artificial intelligence so what is
artificial intelligence or AI this is
where machines that perform jobs that
mimic human behavior now that doesn't
mean that the the technology behind it
has to be complex it could be if-else
statements but it could you be utilizing
machine learning it could be utilizing
deep learning but the point is is that
it mimics human behavior then you have
machine learning and this is where
machines that get better at a task
without explicit programming so they are
smart enough to learn on their own then
you have deep learning and so deep
learning is where machines that have an
artificial neural network inspired by
the human brain to solve complex
problems so literally it's like the
power of the human brain maybe not as
not as great as the human brain but
quite quite close there and AI could be
leveraging ml and deep learning and so
that's why it is like that so when we
want to do machine learning on Azure
they have a service called Azure machine
learning service so this is a service
that that simplifies running AI ml
related workloads allowing you to build
flexible pipelines to automate workflows
so you can use Python and R you can run
your deep learning workloads using
technologies such as tensor flow and so
that's what you'd use now there was a
service called Azure machine learning
studio I think it still around if you if
you're still using it and that's the
classic version of the service and it
does basically what Azure machine
learning service does but there's some
limitations so does not have like
pipeline and other functionalities and
if you're wondering if you could easily
migrate from classic to the other one
it's not easy to migrate so basically
you definitely always want to start with
Azure machine learning service there's
no reason you'd want to use Azure
machine learning studio unless you're
using it for legacy reasons
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we're still looking at AI nml
services specifically just AI services
because a sure has a lot of them and I'm
just going to quickly go through them
and they're pretty self-explanatory so
the first one is personalized it
delivers a rich personalized experiences
for every user using AI then you have
translator it adds real-time
multi-language text translation to your
apps websites and tools you have anomaly
detector detects anomalies and data to
quickly identify and troubleshoot issues
as your BOTS service intelligence
service bought service at scales on
demand form recognizer automate the
extraction of text key value pairs and
tables from your documents you have
computer vision easily customized
computer vision models for unique use
cases language understandings to build a
natural language understanding into apps
BOTS and IOT devices we have QA makers
so create a conversational
question-and-answer bot from your
existing content text analytics extract
information such as sentiment key
phrases named entities and languages
from your text content moderator so
moderate text and images to provide a
safer more positive user experience face
so detect and identify people and
emotions in images Inc a recognizer
recognize digital ink content and such
as handwriting shapes and document
layouts so there you go they have a lot
of services and they haven't even made
time to make all icons for them that's
how many they have hey this is Andrew
Brown from exam pro and we are looking
at service services on Azure so what is
service this is when the underlying
servers or servers infrastructure and OS
is taken care of by the cloud service
provider it will generally be highly
available scalable and cost-effective so
serverless
is event-driven at scale so a service
function can be triggered or trigger
other events allowing you to compose
complex application and just scale so
with serverless technology it's like
playing with Lego blocks then you have
abstraction of servers
servers are distracted away your code is
described as functions these functions
can be running on different compute
instances so if some people like to use
Python or some people like to use
JavaScript you can mix and match there
then you have micro billing so when you
have traditional servers you probably
build by at least a second some bill by
the hour but the thing is if you're not
using the server for the whole second or
hour you're paying for compute that
you're not using so service functions
will bill you in the microsecond so
you're saving money because you're not
paying for unused computation now we'll
just quickly walk through some of the
servlet services I'm sure there's more
than this but this is what I think are
worth highlighting so the first is as
your function so run small amounts of
code known as service functions in your
favorite languages so you got c-sharp
Java JavaScript Python and PowerShell
and if Azure is listening please can you
support Ruby because I love using Ruby
then you have blob storage so this is
service object storage just upload your
files don't think about the underlying
file systems resizing basically
unlimited space and you can upload
pretty darn large files then you have
logic apps allows you to build service
workflows composed of azure functions
building eight I would say this is you
building a state machine for service
compute then you have event bridge which
seems a bit similar but it's not it uses
pub/sub messaging systems to allow you
to react to events and trigger other
azure cloud services such as as your
functions so there you go that is
service services hey this is Angie Brown
from exam Pro and we are looking at the
azure portal so the azure portal is a
web-based unified console that provides
an alternative to command line tools you
can manage your Azure subscription with
the azure portal build manage monitor
everything from simple Web Apps to
complex cloud deployments so what does
that mean it just means the browser that
you use to access a sure so anytime
you're logged into Azure that is the
portal that's all you need to know
there's another thing about Azure portal
and that's as your preview portal so the
thing is is that sometimes there are new
features or new products that Azure has
made that are not necessarily generally
they all
but you can get a sneak peak of them
sooner if you use the azure preview
portal so that could be previews betas
or other pre-releases so the way you do
that is very similar how to you how
you'd access the regular portal but if
you want to test preview of new features
you go to the preview portal Dodger comm
or if you're looking for stable release
in production ready features you just
use portal Dodger calm so that's all you
need to know about the azure portal so I
just wanted to quickly show you what the
portal looks like we are going to show
you in this course how to create your
own account and work within the portal
but I already have one set up here and
I'm already logged in and if I go to the
top here I actually have this portal
link now and when I go here we can see
what the portal looks like so this is
the portal you can see that it's telling
me about my spend but I'm on the
dashboard right now on the left hand
side we have this hamburger menu where
we can explore the services we can go up
here and search them as well so whatever
I'm looking for if it's monitor we can
go there and that's pretty much it this
is the portal so it's just the browser
when you're logged in and you can
interact with any cloud resources
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at powershell for
Azure so first of all what is PowerShell
so PowerShell is a task automation and
configuration management tool but an
easier way to think of it it's just it's
a command-line shell it's also a
scripting language and so when I say a
command-line shell I mean this thing
this blue thing and so if you have a
Windows machine you can actually you'd
have to I think have Windows
Professional but you can go ahead and
install this and it allows you to
automate things using its scripting
language as well as in this this program
now the PowerShell is available on Azure
as well and we'll get to that a moment
let's just talk about the benefits of
PowerShell over traditional traditional
shells though shell could be something
like bass or zsh which would accept and
return text but PowerShell is built on
top of the dotnet common language
runtime so CLR and it accepts and
returns dotnet object
so those objects make it a lot easier to
automate scripting and so PowerShell is
available on Azure and it's known as
Azure PowerShell and so we have a set of
command commandlets
for managing Azure resources directly
from the PowerShell command line and if
you're wondering how you'd access
PowerShell you could use a cloud shell
which we'll talk about here in a moment
okay so I just wanted to quickly show
you a PowerShell I'm on my Windows
computer right now and this is natively
installed on my my Windows 10 computer
and I can type in commands here and so
this is just give me a list of all my my
directories in in this current folder
but I just also want to show you that we
have PowerShell here in the azure portal
so I'm using the cloud shell up here and
I've chosen to use PowerShell and you
can see it's pretty much the same
experience with some extra things that
make it easier to work on cloud so
that's it
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam pro
and we were looking at visual studio
code so Visual Studio code is a free
source code editor meaning it at its
code made by Microsoft for Windows Linux
and Mac OS and you can even run it in
the cloud if you're wondering what it
looks like this is the editor and this
is not to be confused with visual studio
so Visual Studio is an IDE it is also
for programming but it has a lot of
functionality built in here is Visual
Studio code open source well they say
that it is but I don't know to what
degree I don't know if it's 100% open
source but this is the most popular text
editor or code editor out right now and
Microsoft has or sorry Asscher has a
service called it's like visual Studios
workspaces that's on Azure and it allows
you to spin up these developer
environments using this editor right in
the cloud I don't think it's gonna go
your exam but I just thought it was cool
to mention and if you don't have a a
code editor I strongly recommend
downloading this one for your computer
because it is great so I just wanted to
quickly show off Visual Studio code here
so if you wanted to go down with
yourself you just type in Visual Studio
code into Google and you should end up
here
can download a version it's for Windows
Mac and Linux so you can download for
anything and you can run it in the cloud
on Azure or even launch your own server
on other other on other cloud providers
I just have happen to have Visual Studio
code open here with an open source
project just to show you what it looks
like the the thing that people really
like about it's just it looks great and
it has really good plugins so if I just
go to extensions here you can anything
you need you can add it and enhance this
editor here if you don't have a code
editor I strongly recommend downloading
this and I just wanted to make make you
familiar with this editor here hey this
is Andrew Brown from exam pro and we are
looking at Azure cloud shell so Azure
cloud shell is an interactive
authenticated browser accessible shell
for managing resources and so it
provides the flexibility of choosing the
shell experience that best suits the way
you work so you can either use bash or
PowerShell we just talked about
PowerShell and this is the place where
you could use it in Azure so just to
give you a visual if you ever want to
access the cloud shell it's all the way
up in the header there in the portal and
so you click that button it opens up
PowerShell or it will depends on what
you choose but it will open it up down
below and then you'll be able to use
PowerShell right away and also the CLI
right away which we'll talk about next
is the Azure seal hey this is Andrew
Brown from exam prep we are looking at
as your CLI so what does the CLI will
see lies to answer a command line
interface and it processes commands to a
computer program in the form of lines of
text and the operating system implements
a command line interface in a shell or
terminal so we saw a shell earlier which
was PowerShell but we'll look at what
CLI commands look like here in a moment
so the azure CLI can be installed on
Windows Mac and Linux once it's
installed you would type a Z followed by
other commands to create update delete
view and manager as your resources and
so to really show you what that code
looks like down low
we have a bash script but this could
easily be PowerShell and you have the
commands AZ and then you would have what
it is that you want to do so if you
wanted to create a group you type agency
group create and you provide the name
and the location or let's say you wanted
to launch a virtual machine which is a
server you do a zvm create and then
provide those other parameters so that
is how you would program eclis create as
your resources and there's tons and tons
of CLI commands for Azure so basically
anything you're looking at pretty much
can be created with the CLI
programmatically hey this is Andrew
Brown from exam pro and I'm going to
show you how to create resource groups
and the reason why we are going to make
one is because without one we're not
going to be able to launch pretty much
any resource until we do so because you
always have to choose a resource group
when launching as your resources so even
though it shows up here on our dashboard
if it doesn't I want you to go up here
at the top and type in a resource group
and we'll go ahead and click resource
group here and then all the way on the
left hand side I want you to click on
add and we're just going to have to use
our free trial which is there our type
of subscription I'm just going to type
in exam pro as the resource group we're
gonna stay in US East because that is
where the most most of the services are
available asher and that's what i'm
going to be using throughout this course
is always using us east so we'll go down
here and hit create plus for review plus
create because there's really nothing
else to check and once validation pass
this might happen instantaneously for
you you might have to wait a few seconds
go ahead and hit create and so now we
have created our resource group and
there is no cost resource group so
there's no worry about having this or
whether you keep it around don't delete
it you're going to notice that the group
hasn't showed up just yet you're gonna
have to hit refresh and sometimes azure
is a bit slow about showing resources
when you create them initially and when
you delete them so I'm just going to
wait a little bit here and I'm just
going to keep on refreshing and I'll see
you back in a few minutes alright so
waited a couple minutes and if you just
go ahead up
here and hit refresh now we can see that
we have our resource group so that's all
there really is to it nothing super
exciting there I'm just going to click
Microsoft Azure at the top here to get
back to my dashboard and I'll see you in
the next follow along hey this is Andrew
Brown from exam pro and we're going to
look at making our own virtual network
so we made a resource group but we also
need a virtual network or v-net so we
actually have some network tubelaunch
our resources within so what I want you
to do is make your way all the way to
the top here and we're gonna go ahead
and type in V net which will get virtual
networks and go ahead and click that if
you notice you don't have any network so
we're gonna have to go ahead and create
our own so go ahead and hit the Add
button and we're gonna have a bunch of
options here I'm just going to name this
oh sorry we're gonna choose that
resource group so exam pro and we're
just going to name this exam pro v-net
and there are some additional steps here
we'll just take a peek here we don't
really need to change anything but we'll
just take a look so 4 IP address you can
set the IP address space it's going to
default to 1000 for size 16 which is
very good for us you can see that it
supports ipv6 which is great it's going
to create us a default subnet which is
going to be 10 dot 0 dot 0 4/24 that's
going to be a subnet with like 256 IP
addresses which is great go to the
Security tab we have DDoS protection
basic and you definitely want to stay on
that because that is free same thing
with the firewall we don't want it on
because that's gonna cost an extra money
I'm gonna go back to basics we're gonna
hit review plus create we're just gonna
wait for validation to complete this
could be instantaneous for you or you
could wait a few seconds it's different
for everybody
and now the validation has completed
we'll go ahead and hit create and so
we'll just wait for that to finish
creating
great so it's created so it's just
saying deployment is underway so we're
just got to wait a little bit here until
says deployment is complete and it's
already done
superfast and we'll go ahead and hit go
to resource and so now we are in our
virtual network and we have a bunch of
settings on the left hand side so
address space subnets etc etc nothing we
need to know at this level we just need
that virtual network so we can launch
resources in so now that we have
resource groups in virtual network so we
can start launching resources so there
you go I'll see you in the next follow
along
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and I'm going to show you how to launch
your own server on Azure and so a server
would be considered some kind of
computing service and the one we're
going to do right now is we're gonna use
virtual machines so go all the way to
the top here to search and I want you to
type in a virtual machine I know it's on
our dashboard here but just to get in
the habit of always being able to find
stuff it's great to use the search and
then once we're here on the left hand
side I want you to click Add and we're
going to be presented with a lot of
different options so the first thing we
need to do is choose our resource group
we have another resource group tweet
that was created here for us for a sure
I wouldn't worry about let's just choose
the one that we created I'm gonna name
this virtual machine I'm gonna call it
my VM we're gonna launch in US East if
we wanted to choose an AZ we could so we
go to availability zone and choose one
I'm just going to stick to no
infrastructure then we have a bun to
here it's using the latest version it
might be different for you I wouldn't
worry too much about it then we need to
choose our size this is going to really
determine our cost here this is $89
Canadian I'm just gonna go ahead and hit
select here and we're just going to sort
on the right hand side based on cost and
we're going to choose the most
inexpensive server which is the b1 LS so
that's one VP Cu and half a gigabyte of
RAM because this is just an example app
we're not going to do a or a server
we're not going to do anything with it
so might as well make sure we're not
overspending our free credits we have
the option to add a public key this is
what you generally would want to do but
that's a lot of work and so for this
demo so we're just going to choose
password there very finicky about the
password
- that it has to have a uppercase
lowercase special character number and
it also has to be 12 characters so I'm
going to type in testing with a capital
T testing one two three
explanation exclamation and then testing
with a capital on the T one two three
explanation explanation so there we go
we don't need any inbound port so I'm
going to say none because we're not SSA
Qing in I'm just going to click forward
here to show you some of the other
options so we could choose our are the
type of disk we'd be attaching so it's
by default on premium you might want to
standard or standard htd generally when
you're launching what web apps you want
SSD if we'd to choose standard it would
say hey you should really use premium so
we're just going to go back to premium
you're going to notice that the disk is
encrypted by default so you can't have
an unencrypted disk that's a very good
default option if we go over to
networking it's going to automatically
select R or V net that we chose and the
default subnet that we that it created
when we created the V net and then here
we could choose whether we want an IP
address or not if it had no our public
IP address it would still have a private
IP address and that would that would
mean that it would like it's really
intended for a private subnet it has a
network security group set on two basic
here and that's pretty much it here you
could also put it behind a load balancer
we're not going to do that let's go over
to management management we have a
couple options here like identity auto
shut shut down backup these are all
farmers gonna leave it alone for
advanced we could put custom data in
here that means we could provide it a
script that it would use to initially
set up the server we're not going to do
that and that's about it so I'm going to
go back to basic and I'm gonna scroll
all the way down on the bottom and I'm
gonna hit review review plus create and
what we're gonna have to do is wait for
this validation step that was very fast
it might take multiple seconds for you
or even a minute but sometimes it's
faster than others so now I'm going to
go down below and hit create and we're
just going to wait for that deployment
to be submitted it's gonna say
deployment is underway and then soon
it's gonna say deployment is complete so
I'll see you back here in a moment when
deployment is complete
so we had to wait a few minutes there
and now says deployment is complete and
we can proceed to go to resource and so
here's our virtual machine we have some
CPU some networks some disk so there's
some activity here if we wanted to gain
access to it there should be a connect
button here we're not going to be able
to gain access to it because we just
didn't set it up in a way that that was
the case we have a few options down the
left hand side such as the disks that
are actually attached to it and maybe
the size here so it maybe if we wanted
to resize change it to a larger size we
could go ahead and do that but there's
nothing really exciting here to do I
just wanted to show you how to launch
your own virtual machine and now that we
have our own virtual machine launch I'm
gonna go back to overview we're gonna go
ahead and delete that because this is
now costing us money it's not costing us
a lot of money but again we're done here
so we'll just go ahead and delete we're
gonna say yes to delete and now it says
it's still leading the virtual machine
and so we're just going to wait until
this is finished a leading and a lot of
times you can just look at the progress
up here and I'll say deleting the
virtual machine it could take a few
seconds it could take a few minutes it
just depends so all I'll see you here in
a little bit when this is done deleting
so after waiting a little while here it
says it's how it's successfully deleted
the virtual machine if we want to make
sure that it's deleted let's go make our
way over to virtual machines the talker
in the search and you're gonna notice
that it's still showing up there but it
said it was deleted and this is the
thing with Azure is that it takes time
for it to propagate so what we'll have
to do is just hit refresh and now it's
gone so just be aware that sometimes the
consistency in terms of what you've seen
the UI is a bit delayed and so if you
remember clicking delete and it says
that it deleted it just have a bit of
patience there and hit refresh and just
double check to make sure that's the
case so there you go
[Music]
okay great so now that we've done that
let's actually go learn how to do a
different kind of compute which is
serverless functions so if we want to
launch our own service function by the
way if you're not the screen just click
on Microsoft Azure here at the top and
we're gonna go to our search and we're
going to type in functions and so on the
left hand side I want you to click on
add and then what we're doing is we need
to create a function app so we're gonna
be on our free trial we're gonna choose
our resource group we created earlier
we're gonna name this I'm just call this
this is the function app names and just
say my my app my app is now available
these are all unique names and whose
call exam pro app you might have to
change this a few times before you get
what you want and then for publish we're
gonna use code we don't want to use a
docker container that's too much work
and we're gonna just choose no js' which
is just JavaScript version 12 sounds
great to me we're gonna change this to
make it sure that's us East to make our
lives a little easier there's nothing
wrong with central it's just I want
everything to be consistent so
everything's very predictable in these
in these follow longs here we'll go all
the way the top and look at hosting just
quickly here we're gonna see that we
have a storage account ok nothing
exciting here it's going to either be
Linux or Windows this doesn't really
matter to us we can let it be windows
we're going back to basic I'm gonna go
ahead and hit review plus create so
we're gonna wait for this validation to
step to complete here so again it could
take a second or it could take a minute
just depends on the day with Azure so
we'll just wait here a little bit there
we go it's just finished validating I'm
going to go ahead and hit create and now
we're waiting for that initial
deployment so we're gonna see that
deployment is on its way
and then we have to wait for deployment
to be complete so it's in progress it's
underway this shouldn't take too long
and should say that it's complete here
in a moment
great so after waiting in a few minutes
here our deployment is complete we'll go
ahead and hit go to resources so now
what we need to do is we need to go
create ourselves a function so on the
left hand side make your way to function
and then in here we're gonna add
ourselves a new function and so we have
a lot of presets here for us it's not
going to matter what we choose while it
does and I'm going to say let's choose
HTTP trigger we're going to leave with
the default name that's fine we'll have
it stay as function for authorization
level we'll go ahead and create that
function so once that function is has
been created here and it's already done
let's start adding our code because
again the whole point of server list is
that you don't have to worry about
servers you just add your code and it
works and so here's some code it already
has for us what I'm going to do is I'm
just gonna add myself a console log
console log is just like saying hello
world so we're going to say hello world
and then I'm gonna hit save and now it's
just connecting to application insights
I don't know if it's actually running it
yeah it's connected great and now let's
go ahead and hit test and so we have a
bunch of options here I'm not going to
fill it anything I'm just gonna hit run
and we're gonna see what the output is
okay great so you know I'm just looking
at how this actually works and I think
what we need to do is we need to
actually pass a name into the to the
query string here so what we'll do is
we're just going to go ahead and type in
query here and we'll put a name and
we'll say Andrew and so that should do
it so let's just hit run ok great so
it's saying hello Andrew so there you go
that's all you have to do to create a
service function and it doesn't cost us
anything to keep this around so we don't
necessarily have to delete it if you did
want to go delete it I guess we go back
here we'd have to go back to functions
here and I would just click delete
and we'll type in yes it will hit delete
and there you go so that's that's all
there is there there to it for serve
let's compute I go back to Microsoft
Azure here back to the dashboard and
we'll see you in the next follow along
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown and in this
video I'm going to show you how to set
up blob storage and so if you remember
through the actual course blob storage
is like servlet storage so you don't to
worry about running out of space or
resizing your disks so let's go to it
at the top here I want you to type in
blob storage and you're going to go to
storage accounts and this is where you
end up creating all of your storage
accounts you can see that we have a
couple storage devices from the virtual
machine and when we created the service
the service function there so go ahead
and hit add and what we're gonna do is
choose exam pro or whatever you called
yours when we were at the resource group
step then we're gonna have a storage
device I'm gonna say my blob storage
well that's to be all lowercase my blob
storage and that's already taken so
we'll say exam pro blob storage and it
can't have hyphens there we go
and so we're gonna launch it in u.s.
East we have the difference between
standard and premium I think we'll stick
with standard we have storage type v2 or
v1 or blob storage we want blob storage
we have some replication options here
I'm just gonna leave it alone we have
access to here hot or cool we're just
going to leave it hot and we can just
look at networking here for a moment
we're gonna leave this alone we're just
gonna be advanced in a moment so nothing
exciting there we'll go back to basic
hit review plus create we'll have to
wait for validation we'll go ahead and
now hit create and then it should say
deployment underway we're waiting to see
this a deployment complete you might be
getting into the rhythm of how creating
services now it's almost always the same
process
and we'll just wait here till this is
complete okay great so I just waited a
minute there and now that's all set up
so let's go ahead and hit go-to resource
and then we have a lot of stuff around
here so what we want to do is we want to
start uploading files but I think we
have to create a container first so go
all the way down here left out inside
and go to containers then we're gonna
create a new container I'm gonna call
this Star Trek it's going to be a
private container so it's only just for
me we'll hit create and now we should be
able to click into that container all
right so now we now that we have that
container what we can do is go ahead and
upload our first file I just happen to
have a file on my desktop here so I'm
just gonna go select that there and
upload all the options by default are
great here we'll just hit upload and
there we go so we just upload a file
into our blob storage yeah so that's all
there really is to it so now that we're
all done there we can just go ahead and
delete this container so I think we'll
just go back to storage accounts I'm not
sure we have to delete the containers
first I guess we'll find out and we'll
just go here to blob storage we'll go
ahead and hit delete and we'll hit yes
it'll go to delete and there you go so
we'll just go back to Microsoft Azure
there and back on our desktop and I'll
see you in the next fall alone hey this
is Andrew Brown from exam Pro and I'm
going to show you how to use cloud
shells so if you want to it actually
doesn't matter where you are because
cloud shell is accessible anywhere when
you're in the azure portal it's actually
this icon up here so what I want you to
do is go ahead and click that and what
it's going to do is ask you whether you
want bash or PowerShell I'm going to
choose PowerShell we're going to use our
free tier and what we're going to need
to create some storage with it I'm just
gonna drag that up there a bit so we'll
just wait for it to create that storage
device
and so now we get this blue screen which
is very typical of PowerShell and so
it's gonna have to initialize our
account so we're just going to wait here
a little bit until that's done
great and so now we have our cloud shell
and so one of the advantages of having
cloud shell is that if you want to do
the CLI and start doing things
programmatically within a sure you can
do that very easily here so we already
have the CLI installed so we can just
type in AZ whoops just typing clear here
a Z account list and there you go so we
got some account information back there
so that's all I wanted to show you for
PowerShell we can go ahead here and I
think we can just power it off well that
would restart it we just hit X and there
you go that's it hey this is Andrew
Brandt from exam pro and we are looking
at the azure trust center so all it is
it's a public-facing website portal
providing easy access to privacy
security and regulatory compliance
information so there it is that is the
portal if you type in Azure trust Center
that's the way you get to it and the
idea here is that you know whatever
information your organization needs it's
just all public facing so you don't even
have to login to get access to it but it
just helps you make security decisions
for your company alright so I just want
to head there and went to Google and
typed in Microsoft trust Center and so
this is the page here so if we just
scroll on down here a little bit we'll
see that we have Microsoft Azure and
here we have a bunch of options where we
can read about their security privacy
privacy and compliance let's go into
compliance for Azure and here we can see
a list of a bunch of compliance programs
that Azure is meeting so we have a ton
here so if we went into gdpr it might
ask us to sign in um so I'll just hit
Andrew in Canada and I agree okay and so
now I can read all about gdpr so it
gives me a lot of detailed information
about this compliance program and how it
applies to Azure so there's a lot of
interesting stuff here I'll just go back
here we can click on security
and so there's just some generalized
information here but generally what
you're looking for when you are coming
to here is really this compliance
programs that's what everybody is always
looking for is to read about that stuff
in detail and so that's all you have to
do to get there so yeah there you go hey
this is Angie Brown from exam Pro and we
were looking at compliance programs for
a juror so enterprise companies will not
buy your software solutions unless they
are secure and so how would you go about
meeting their security compliance
requirements and that's where compliance
programs come in to come into play
so basically enterprise companies gonna
say to you we'll only do business with
you if you are Miss compliant or if
you're p.i PDA compliant or if you are
HIPAA compliant or if you are FIPS 140 -
2 compliant you might say well that's a
lot of stuff but you know after a while
you just start to remember them but at
first it is really daunting but I
thought it'd be fun to go through some
of the compliance programs and it
actually might show up in your exam they
might ask you about some of these
programs so we'll just go down the list
so the first one here is the criminal
justice information services that C J is
so this is any US state or local agency
that wants to access the FBI's CJIs
database is required to adhere to this
security policy so that's their
compliance program then you have the
Cloud Security Alliance star
certification this is an independent
third-party assessment of a cloud
providers security posture then you have
general data protection regulation the
gdpr so a European privacy law imposes
new rules on companies government
agencies nonprofits and other organs and
services to people in the EU or collect
and analyze data ty de residents so if
you're dealing with data in the EU you
gotta care about the GD P R you have EU
model clauses so contextual contractual
guarantees around transfers of personal
data outside the EU then you have HIPAA
so this is the one that you're gonna
want to remember this is the Health
Insurance Portability and Accountability
Act so for US federal law that regulates
patient protected health information
whenever you're doing with hospital
stuff you're dealing with HIPAA then you
have is ISO two seven zero one eight so
this is an international standard and it
is the code of practice or so code of
practice covering the processing of
personal information by cloud service
providers that's a good one to remember
then we have ID a so this is a
multi-tier cloud security Singapore
started seeing reporter IDs Singapore's
the the organization but this one is a
called MT CS so operational Singapore
security management standard a standard
a common standard that cloud service
providers can apply to address customer
concerns about the security and
confidential confidentiality of data in
the cloud impact on businesses of using
cloud services not when you have to
remember but interesting now this one
you want to remember service
organization controls sock one two and
three independent third-party
examination reports to demonstrate how
the Company achieves key compliant
controls and objectives yeah I know
there's a lot sorry then we have the
National Institute of Standards
Technology NIST cybersecurity framework
CSF you definitely want to know this one
it's a voluntary framework that consists
of standard guidelines and best
practices to manage cybersecurity
related risks then you have the UK
government G cloud so that's cloud
computing certification for services
used by government entities in the UK
and the last one is FIPS and we will be
talking about hips again in this course
here so this is a US and Canadian
government standard that specifies the
security requirements for cryptographic
modules that protect sensitive
information so there you go that's
compliance programs
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at has your Active
Directory so as your Active Directory
abbreviated to ad is Microsoft's
cloud-based Identity and Access
Management Service which helps your
employees sign in and access resources
if you work for a larger company and
they use Microsoft products they're
probably using Active Directory and
you're already familiar with this but if
you're not let's learn up on this
because this is a super important
service to the azure and Microsoft
ecosystem so Azure directory would work
with external resources so it would
maybe give you access to your office 365
to the azure portal which is what we're
using it for two different types of SAS
applications it could also grant us
access to internal resources so if you
have applications running within your
network or maybe you're using Azure
Active Directory to gain access to
actual workstations on-premise so actual
workstations with Azure Active Directory
you can implement single sign-on and
Azure Active Directory comes in four
editions so we have free which provides
MFA SSO basic security and uses reports
user management then we have the next
level up office 365 and by the way each
version up has the features prior to it
so with office 365 apps you get company
branding SLA to sync between on-prem and
cloud which is really nice for premium
one you get hybrid architecture advanced
group access can conditional access and
then premium two you have identity
production and identity governance but
if I didn't make it clear Active
Directory is what you use to help your
employees sign in and access resources
that is what it does it controls access
to resources so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at multi-factor
authentication so what is MFA so MFA is
a security control where after you fill
in your username or maybe it's your
email and password into a login portal
so this login portal could be the azure
portal this could be you logging into
Facebook the idea is that you have to
use a second device such as a phone to
confirm that it's you logging in and so
why do we use MFA well MFA protects
against people who have stolen your
password because they might have your
password but they don't have your phone
or whatever device that they're you're
using for MFA so MFA is an option most
cloud providers have and just as I said
before most social media websites have
it so Facebook Twitter they all have it
so just to give you a visual example we
have a form where I'm entering my email
and password then we have a phone which
is our MFA in this case and then we get
authorization so in the first case that
is one factor right so if we didn't have
to use a phone or another device that we
couldn't considered one factor and then
multi-factor or two-factor
authentication would be the the addition
of another device to confirm that it
that it's you and pretty what pretty
much what's common is to use your phone
and to install an app on your phone and
then what that phone will do is it will
give you a random number that expires
like every I don't know 10 seconds you
have to enter that in with your username
and password or as the second step and
then you gain access to as your portal
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at as your security
center so azure security center is a
unified infrastructure security
management system it strengthens the
security posture of your data centers
and provides advanced threat protection
across your hybrid workloads in the
cloud that sounds really fancy but let's
take a look at what that is so that's
what it is down below it's a bunch of
graphs and it's going to tell you if you
are compliant with particular policies
they'll tell you about your security
hygiene all sorts of security stuff so
you have a good visual about your
security within a sure so
there you go hey this is Angie Brown
from exam pro and we're looking at key
vaults so as your key vault helps you
safeguard cryptographic keys and other
secrets used by cloud apps and services
and so within key Balt it has a bunch of
functionality in it so one thing it can
do is manage your secrets so store a
store and tightly control access to
tokens password certificates API keys
and other secrets it also has key
management so it can create and control
encryption keys used to encrypt your
data then we have certificate management
so easily provision manage and deploy
public and private ssl certificates for
use with Azure and internal connected
resources and then it also is a hardware
security module so secrets and keys can
be protected either by software or FIPS
140-2 or 140 - 2 level - validated HSM I
told you that we would be talking about
tips again and we are right now so to
understand HSM the last thing we're
talking about which stands for a
hardware security module it's a piece of
hardware designed to store your
encryption keys and it literally looks
like something like that so I sure would
have bought one of these or uh tons of
these and that is what is storing your
cryptographic keys and this piece of
hardware is special because when you
store keys on it they're stored in
memory meaning that they're not written
to disk if that thing shuts down the
keys are gone and nobody can steal your
data it's just a security measure and
that security measure has to do with
FIPS okay so FIPS 140 - 2 is a US and
Canadian government standard that
specifies the security requirements for
cryptographic modules to protect
sensitive information
so for HSMs that are multi-tenant
they're generally going to be a 140 - 2
compliant multi-tenant meaning that that
there's more than one customer that is
using that piece piece of hardware but
they're virtually isolated from each
other and then if you have a single
tenant HSM they're generally going to be
FIPS 140 - 3 compliant so a single
customer
on a dedicated em it's better to be FIPS
140 - 3 compliant but what tips 140 - 2
is pretty good for most people so there
you go hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and we were looking at Azure
DDoS protection so before we talk about
DDoS protection let's talk about what
DDoS is and that stands for distributed
denial of service attack this is a
malicious attack to disrupt the normal
traffic by flooding a web site with
large amounts of fake traffic so to get
this better visualize imagine there is
somebody that doesn't like you and you
have your servers and they want to
attack you and they want to stop your
your server from running so what they
can do is they can send a remote command
to a bunch of computers that they
control and these could also be in a
cloud service provider or their own data
center and from a foreign country and
what they'll do is they will send
thousands upon thousands of fake
requests to your servers so they'll
they'll have packets that they're
setting to you with IP addresses all
those IP addresses are made-up so we so
they're just fake traffic and then they
will flood you with so much traffic that
your your servers are going to crash the
network is going to crash you're not
going to be able to do anything but the
great thing is is that the majority of
cloud service providers including Azure
have built-in DDoS protection so just by
using a cloud service provider you're
going to have a certain level of
protection against DDoS attacks and to
talk about the different levels azor
offers two tiers of DDoS protection so
DDoS protection basic is free it's
already turned on it's it protects all
of Asura's global network so if you are
using Azure you already get DDoS
protection if you need something more
advanced because the attacks are
extremely more complex and you need more
visibility and you need a professional
support there's the DDoS protection
standard plan so that starts at two
thousand nine hundred and forty four
dollars you might say that's high but
trust me
I've experienced ddossing and when you
are DDoS you are willing to pay that
amount and it works right away
you'd get metrics alerts reporting you'd
get a DDoS expert so that you can talk
to you or a team that you can talk to
and they'd have a guarantee of
application cost protection so SLA so if
if they couldn't prevent the attack and
it you lost the cost of money they're
going to give you credits or help you
out okay so that is DDoS protection for
a sure
[Music]
hey this is Angie ran from exam Pro and
we are looking at as your firewall which
is a managed cloud-based network
security service that protects your as
your virtual network resources so the
way it works is you're going to set up a
V net which is a virtual network and
you're gonna attach that firewall you're
going to use it as a point of entry for
all your traffic and then what you're
going to do is you're going to have
spoke V net so when I say spoke I just
mean other virtual networks that you've
created that are intermediate to your
traffic so the trap is going to pass
through that V net into those other ones
and our V now with the firewall is going
to decide what traffic's allowed to flow
through what's not to which other V Nets
that have specific virtual machines so
that we get protection but let's talk
about some of the features of the azure
firewall so the first thing is you you
essentially create enforce it centrally
creates enforce and logs application
network connectivity policies across
subscriptions and virtual network so
subscriptions being multiple accounts
uses a static public IP address for your
virtual network resources allowing
outside firewalls to identify traffic
originating from your virtual network
that's very useful high availability is
built in at no additional cost so you
don't have to create load bouncers and
do all that work yourself you can
configure you can configure it during
deployment to spend multiple AZ's so
that it has high availability there's no
additional costs for a firewall deployed
in an availability zone there's an
additional cost for inbound and outbound
data transfers associated with AZ's
which you
is is typical so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we were looking at Azure information
protection also known as a IP and what
this does is it protects sensitive
information such as your emails or
documents with encryption and it
restricts access based on rights and
it's integrated directly into Office
apps so if you're using PowerPoint or
word or exchange or any of the Microsoft
360 suite what you're gonna have is this
button called protect and you can drop
it down and you can change the access
controls the privacy controls of your
data and this is really important if you
are a larger corporation and this kind
of stuff really matters to you so that
is as your information protection just
think of that button that you click and
then you have those security controls
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam pro
and we were looking at as your
application gateway so I believe we
talked about application gateway earlier
and it is a load bouncer specifically
it's an application load balancer so it
operates all in layer 7 so it's dealing
with HTTP requests and because it's
dealing with HTTP requests it can
actually understand the nature of a
request and you can create rules to
route traffic to other places another
really great feature of as your
application gateway is you can attach a
web application firewall and it will
protect on the layer 7 so you can set up
rules just as you are setting up routing
rules you can set up security rules
about what should be able to flow in and
out of this load bouncer to give you a
visual down below you have the internet
you have your application gateway and
you can optionally attach your your wife
to it and as traffic flows through it
you can create some rules so let's say
you had a server that served up all your
JavaScript assets and a server that
server DUP all your images you could
make a rule that saying when the path
matches this only send it to this server
and when the path matches that only send
it to that server ok so there's a there
you go that's as your application
gateway
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at as your advanced
threat protection also known as ATP and
so before we talk about the service
let's talk about what is IDs and IPS I
know there's a lot of acronyms being
thrown at you today so ID S stands for
intrusion detection system and IPS
stands for intrusion protection system
and what that is it's a piece of
technology that monitors a network or
systems for malicious activity activity
or policy violations and so the
difference between an IDP and IPS is or
a sorry IDs and an IPS is an IDs to text
and an IPS protects so it actually takes
action in the latter now I'm not sure if
advanced advanced threat protection is
just an IDs it or an IPS but it doesn't
hurt to call in the same category it's
not a big deal so it as your advanced
threat protection ATP is a cloud-based
security solution that leverages your
on-premise Active Directory signals to
identify detect and investigate advanced
threats compromised identities and
malicious insight actions directed at
your organization so there you go that's
what it does hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam pro and we were looking at the
Microsoft security of do development
lifecycle also known as SDL or some
people might call it M SD l so SD l is
an industry-leading security security
assurance process and it's a microsoft
wide initiative in a mandatory policy
since 2004 so that means Microsoft uses
it because they made it the SDL has
played a critical role in embedding
security and privacy in Microsoft
software software and culture so
building security into each STL phase of
the development lifecycle helps you
catch issues earlier and it helps you
reduce your development costs so it's
talking about these phases these are the
phases for it so you have training
requirements design implementation
verification release response if you
to implement this yourself I bet they
have a big way paper on it like a PDF
you can read through but it's just a
business process and it's just saying
the sooner we implement stuff into our
pipeline in terms of development the
sooner we can reduce security risks and
that is actually called pushing left
because the farther left you start
implementing security the earlier on the
the better your security will be in your
entire pipeline so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at policies so an
azure policy is a service that you can
use to create assign and manage policies
a policy allows you to enforce or
control the properties of a resource and
as your policy evaluates resources in
Azure by comparing the properties of
those resources to business rules and
these business rules described in JSON
format are known as policy definitions
so if it's not clear just yet do not
worry we're going to be looking at
policy definitions very soon but just
understand what Azure policies do
they're used to create assign manage
policies and enforce and control
properties of your resources
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at Azure role based
access controls RBAC
so this is it a service in particular
but it's more of a concept of how all
the components of gaining access to
resources works so as your role based
access control helps you manage who has
access to resources what they can do
with those resources and what areas they
have access to so you have role
assignments and this is the way you
control access to resources so a role
assignment consists of three elements
you have the security principle the role
definition and the scope so talking
about the security principle first this
represents the identity requesting
access to the azure resource so this is
who wants to have access you have you
could have a user which is an individual
profile in your Azure Active Directory
you could have a group of users in your
Azure Active Directory you could have a
service principal so this is a security
identity used by applications
services to access specific resources
this is what a service wants access and
you have managed identity this is
identity in Azure Active Directory that
is automatically managed by a sure that
one's a bit more harder to describe but
that's not that important for the exam
then the last partner component here is
scope so this is the set of resources
that the set of resources that the role
assignment is going to be granted access
to so scoping scope access controls at
the management subscription or resource
group level so to explain that the idea
that I'm trying to get here is that you
have resources down below right and that
is what you want to gain access to but
you can set scope at the management
group level you can set scope at the
subscriptions level you can set scope at
the resource groups levels so just to
talk about those three management group
is when you're managing a bunch of
accounts subscription is an individual
account and resource groups is a
grouping of resources so wherever you
want to apply that scope you can choose
any any one of those three there now
looking at a role definition so a role
definition is a collection of
permissions and so remember we were
talking about a policy earlier this is
kind of where that comes in and because
policies are permissions a role
definition lists the operations that can
be performed such as the read write and
delete roles can be high level like
owner or specific like a virtual machine
reader and just to give you an example
so Azure has built-in roles and you can
define your own custom roles but I think
you have to pay more to be able to do
custom roles because that's through
Azure Active Directory but the built-in
roles you need to know which is owner
contributor reader and user access
administrator these are the four
fundamental built-in roles now look at
the the graphic there we have the green
and the red so for an owner you can read
you can grant you can create up update
and delete resources you can do
everything as a contributor all you can
do is read create update and delete you
can't grant access you can't you can't
allow other users to gain access to your
resources then you have a reader so a
reader as the name implies can only read
resources they can't create up and
delete they can't grant access to
users and then a user access
administrator only grant so their job is
to give access to other resources but
they can't do anything themselves so
there you go that is role based access
controls hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and we are looking at LOC
resources so as an admit you may need to
lock a subscription resource group or
resource to prevent other users from
accidentally letting other users delete
or modify critical resources so in the
azure portal you can set the following
lock levels you can set it to be cannot
delete and so in the azure portal this
would just be called delete and this
authorized this will allow authorized
users can still read and modify resource
but they cannot delete the resource then
you have read-only and in the azure
portal it's going to be read - only and
this is so that authorized users can
read a resource but they can't delete or
update a resource
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and let's look at Azure management group
so azure management groups is a way of
managing multiple multiple subscriptions
and when you hear the word subscriptions
in Azure just think accounts because
that's an easier way to think about it
into a hierarchical structure so each
directory is given a single top-level
management group called the route
management group all subscriptions
within a management group automatically
inherit the conditions applied to the
management group and so this is a
graphical representation so at the top
you have your route management group and
then create management groups underneath
so Human Resources IT marketing
production developers whatever you want
and underneath you have those individual
subscriptions again just think of them
like an account so that is as your
management groups
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at as your monitor so
as your monitor is a comprehensive
solution for collecting analyzing and
acting on telemetry telemetry from your
cloud and on-premise environment so if
you were to go in as your monitor on the
left hand side you'd see all these
options activity log alerts metrics logs
service health etc and so that's what as
your monitor is it's it's like an
umbrella for a bunch of services
underneath and so here's an example of a
bunch of information in the form of a
dashboard about monitoring and analytics
so with as your monitor you can create a
visual dashboard as we can see here you
can create smart alerts you can create
automated actions and you can collect
logs so that you have log monitoring so
there you go hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam pro and we're looking at as
your service howl so this is about
information about current upcoming
issues such as service impacting events
planned maintenance and other changes
that may affect your availability so
going down the list we have as your
status which informs you of service
outages in Azure as your service health
ape is a personalized view of the health
of the azure service and regions you're
using and then as your resource health
is information about the health of the
individual cloud resources such as your
VM so if you're ever wondering the state
of your health you can use Azure service
health and if you noticed it was an
option under as your monitor so if
you're looking for it that's where you
go to find it
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we were looking at as your advisor
so average as your adviser is a
personalized cloud consultant that helps
you follow best practices to optimize
your as your deployments the adviser
dashboard displays personalized
recommendations for all your
subscriptions for the following five
categories high availability security
performance class and operational
excellence and since we are in the
security category that's what we most
care about is security but it would also
be important for the pricing a section
there as well so the first we're gonna
look at is actually the Azure adviser
recommendation for costs so here you can
see that it's telling you where the most
impact can occur and leaving tell you
how much money you can save if you
follow its recommendations then you have
security and so here it has 21
recommendations if we were to click into
it it would tell you what kind of things
that you could improve in your system to
improve your security so there you go
that's as your advice
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at SLE A's for Azure
so SLA stands for service level
agreement and this describes Asher's
commitment for uptime and connectivity
that that means like if you have a web
server as yours gonna say yeah we
guarantee 99.9% of the time it's going
to remain running throughout the year
it's not going to go down so that's kind
of the idea behind an SLA for as your
SLA czar into the individualized / Azure
service so they don't have broad SLA s
you're gonna have to investigate each
service to figure out what the
commitment of Azure is for that service
and the way we describe these SLA is in
terms of uptime and connectivity is
through performance targets now a
performance target is just a
representation in the form of a
percentage so if somebody were to say to
you
you know this service has 99 percent
likely of not failing
that's called two nines and then you
have the three nines and then you have
five nines and then you have nine nines
and the higher this number goes up the
more reliable the the better coverage
this SLA is going to give you so you
want something
it has a higher number of nines and it's
not always just nines it could be 99.95%
but just understand that when someone
says nine 9's they're talking about that
last value there and it is like one of
the highest one of the highest
guarantees an SLI can give a camera
there's like 11 9s there might be 11 9s
but generally nine 9's is the upper
limit and just to mention is that for a
sure if you are using the free tier of
shared tears you do not get SLA because
they just do not provide support for
those because you're consuming
everything for free so you have to be
paying to get the advantage of that SLA
guarantee so I did say that the SLA czar
service specific and so if you want to
actually go investigate all you got to
do is type in as your SLA into Google
and you should be able to make your way
to this page and what we can do is we
can click into any of these here so if I
go to database and we choose cosmos DB
and we just expand our information here
we get tons of information about there
SL ace and then our performance targets
are down here so we've got this for
availability this is for read
availability so they have a lot of
information and as I said it's for
basically any service anything you want
just click into it and they have all
that SLA information so there you go hey
this is Angie Brown from exam pro and we
are looking at service credits for Azure
so the service credit is when a custom
customer would get a discount on their
as your bill as competent as
compensation for an underperforming as
your product or service based on the SLA
so those guarantees that azure gives if
they don't meet those guarantees then
they owe you money and the way they do
it is through credits right so credits
is just like virtual money I actually
don't know what a like what a service
credit is worth but I just know that you
know if they if they do not meet those
SLA is they're gonna back it and give
you your money back in some sense so
just an example here if we have as your
virtual machine remember a virtual
machine is a server if you had monthly
uptime percentage of 99.9 so if it was
under that the
you get a service credit of 10% if it
was under 99 then you get a service
credit of 25% and if it was under 95 you
get a service credit of a hundred
percent so I guess what that means is
maybe it's the cost of what you spent
but anyway I'm not exactly sure but I
would take a guess that if let's say the
uptime was under ninety five percent and
they're gonna give you a service credit
a hundred percent maybe it's a hundred
percent of your resources given back to
you so if you spend $100 you get that
hundred dollars back so there you go hey
this is Andrew Brown from exam pro and
we were looking at composite SLA so we
had said earlier that different services
have different SLA s and the problem
with that is that when you have
different services different SLA is it's
kind of hard to understand what the
actual guarantee is when you use them in
combination so comps at SLA is is just a
way of understanding what the actual SLA
guarantee underneath is for the
performance target so imagine you have a
web application and that web application
uses an SQL database so the web app has
a guarantee of 99.95% because maybe
that's the the performance target for
the virtual machine and then the SQL
database is 99.99% so what is it is it
ninety five ninety nine point nine five
percent or is it four nines we don't
know so if we have to calculate it
calculate that for the SLA with the web
app and SQL database that would come out
to 99.94% don't ask me on the math that
is the example that we are given but
just understand that that's what it
would come out to become it would come
out to 99.94% and so you'd have an
overall reduction of the SLA whereas the
SQL database would have ninety-nine
point nine percent so how could we
improve our SLA and consider that in our
design so we get the the SLA that we
want and so you can do is you can add in
fallback systems that will improve the
overall SLA and if you logically think
about it it makes sense why that would
work so imagine you have that SQL
database and it goes down but if you had
a queue and that queue was saving all
the transaction attempts that the web
app was trying to write to the database
and saving the queue
it wouldn't matter if the database went
down because once the database won back
up all those transactions would be there
and then those transactions would then
complete and so by using the queue which
has a 99.9% uptime based on the math
down below again don't ask me how the
math works but the the the outcome would
be an SLA of 99.95% and so that's an
improvement over 99.94%
so that is composite essays and there
you go hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and we are looking at the TCO
calculator for a sure so if you remember
earlier in the course we talked about
the total cost of ownership that's what
TCO stands for it's about showing an
impaired enterprise that that operates
on premise how much money they would
save if they moved on to cloud onto
azure so that's what the TCO calculator
does it estimates the cost savings you
can realize by migrating your workloads
to Azure so what it can do is it can
generally generate out a detailed report
and export as a PDF to send to your
decision-makers now you have to input
all the information in but it's going to
help you convince your boss to convince
the executive level that it's time to
move over to the cloud because they'll
be saving tons and tons of money and so
if you want to use that calculator you
just got to go to Azure Microsoft com4
slash pricing for size calculator and
it's going to give you an idea of how
much you'll save no this is only a
little bit of what it generates out
because it's a very detailed report but
in this example it would compare
on-premise add to the cost savings of
Azure and in this case this person would
be saving a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars over five years and it's going
to vary on use case but yeah that is the
TCO calculator so I just wanted to
quickly show you the TCO calculator in
action if you want to find it yourself
to type in Azure TCO calculator into
Google and you should be able to find
your way here so what I've done here is
I've defined my workload so in my
workflow tied to find some servers so we
have some Linux servers we have ten of
them four processes four cores eight
gigabytes of RAM and then here I've
added four servers that are databases
running Postgres then I added
some HDD drives so I said three
terabytes two terabytes backup etc and
then I defined some network bandwidth so
going on to the next step we're going to
adjust our assumptions this helps us to
make it even more accurate the estimate
so we can choose our our currency some
other additional features we might want
to consider where we might save money
like using as your hybrid benefit and
then down below we can tweak some of our
costs that we do know about for our
on-prem so there's a lot here to tweak
it to make it more accurate and then if
we go to next we're going to get our our
savings here so just wait a moment and
so over a five year period we should
save six hundred and sixty six dollars
and one hundred fifty eight cents and
you can drop it down if you want to do
one year we'll go to one year so here it
says three hundred eighty one dollars
and we have a lot of graphics here as
you can see and then down below you
should be able to download it so you can
just go ahead and download the results
there and that is the TCO calculator hey
this is Angie Brown from exam Pro and we
are looking at the azure marketplace so
the azure marketplace is a place where
there are apps and services made
available to you by third-party
publishers to quickly get started on
Azure and so the apps available of the
apps and services that can be available
could be free they could be free trial
that could be paid you go or that could
be bring your own license so just an
example of what that looks like if you
were logged into the azure portal and
you searched for a marketplace what you
could do here is you could type in a
variety of things so like here I'm
typing in WordPress and here I have a
bunch of word presses that are provided
by third-party publishers that have been
vetted by asher and and again they could
cost money they could have a free trial
they could be 100% free but whatever you
need it's generally in the marketplace
it's a great place to go checkout so
just be aware of that so I just wanted
to quickly show you the azure
marketplace so you'd have to have an
account to actually see it but we do
show you that in this course but anyway
I'm just going to go up here to the top
and type in marketplace and this will
pull up the marketplace and here you can
see we have a
a huge amount of categories of things
that we can launch so whatever we need
and I think I showed before WordPress
but we'll type that in there so enter in
WordPress and there's all these servers
so you can click into there it might it
might have plans associated with it if
there's any price but you just go ahead
and hit create and then that would start
the process of creating a virtual
machine and you go through that and you
subscribe to whatever the underlying
cost would be but you can see there's
just tons of stuff in here so and you
can sort by price sort by operating
system so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at as your support
plans and so we have four support plans
we have basic developer standard and
professional direct technically we have
five and we count Enterprise I don't
think it's going to be on the exam and
there's not a lot of information around
it because you've got to call sales to
find out that those enterprise price and
support so let's just go through the
difference between these things it's
definitely important for your exam so
we're looking at the basic support plan
and everybody gets the basic support
plan when you sign up you get email
support only for billing and account so
if you have any questions about your
bills or questions about your account
you can get answers from support now for
developer standard and professional
direct you get tech support and you get
email tech support for all levels and
generally if we're talking just for
developer they're only gonna reply
during the business hours but if you had
standard or professional direct they had
people answering emails 24/7 around the
clock I think the general response time
for email support no matter what level
it is is about 24 hours but you know
it's just gonna vary so I would say that
if you need something that is more
urgent then you're going to want that
phone support and so formal support is
for standard and professional direct and
that's 24/7 so if it's a Saturday and
it's 9:00 p.m. and you need a call
support you can do that and sometimes
you only have to wait 10 to 15 minutes
I'm not sure if asher has a chat but
it's very common for cloud service
providers to provide both chat and phone
support and you wait 10 to 15 minutes
and you get access there
now for third-party support if you are
using technologies like Ruby on Rails
spring Django those things aren't really
part of azure they're third-party
software that you're using to build your
web application and azure is going to
try to do their best effort to support
you even though it's not what they've
built and that's not what they have to
do but they're going to do their best
effort for a developer standard and
professional direct so that is advantage
for paying for support now in terms of
response times when you open up a ticket
you can say the severity of your ticket
and that's going to determine how fast
they respond if you need the response so
if there's a ticket and you say that it
has minimal business impact so maybe
it's like general questions or something
that's gonna be considered a severity C
and for developer and standards they're
gonna respond within eight hours or less
for professional director can get that
in four hours or less so again that's
just general questions now if you have
something that it's going to have a
moderate business impact then the time
is going to be a lot faster they call
that severity B so it's going to be less
than four hours and then for
professional direct it's going to be
less than two hours and so this would be
if your production system was
compromised but it's not taking your
business down now if you have a critical
business impact that means your your web
app is 100% down and you are losing
money by the minute you open up a ticket
called critical business impact which is
severity C actually should be severity a
it's just a spelling mistake there but
it they would respond within an hour or
less so what I find is that there's like
even though they say an hour or less
it's not always the case but that's
generally how fast they're going to
respond now for other services you get
as your advisor to health status the
community support an azure documentation
and all these support plans the only
reason we're mentioning this here and
they mention it on their support page
but they're just trying to say hey just
be aware that you have these additional
support tools that you can use at any
given time that are self-serve so the
community sport and the azure documents
now if you need some general guidance on
your architecture you're gonna get that
with developer and standards so you can
definitely ask questions there if you
are using professional direct you
actually get access to a team and that
in that team there's a pool of people
that you may you may get when when you
talk to them where they'll give you a
guidance and they call those operational
support and proactive guidance by by pro
direct delivery managers so professional
direct is called pro direct and so they
have delivery managers I don't know if
that means that they're developers but
the point is is that they're going to
put some extra effort to help you there
and then also you can actually access
webinars led by Azure engineers so
that's really cool as well if you pay
for the professional direct so just
going through all the support plans here
for the pricing so basic is free and
when you sign up if you don't choose the
plan you are using basic and then for
developer is $29 per month USD for
standard it's $100 USD per month and for
professional direct it's a thousand USD
dollars per month so there you go that
is the azure support plans so I just
wanted to show you how to get to this
support plan page in case you want to
investigate a bit further but pretty
much my graphic sums up everything that
is included in the support plans so if
you want to find this you just go to as
you're just type into Google as your
support plans and you should be able to
make your way here you'll notice we have
the floor plans and then there's
enterprise support and if we go here
there's more information on this but
again you'll have to call support to
find out the actual price and offerings
there but yeah just take a look here and
see if there's anything I miss but I'm
pretty sure I have everything you need
in the main graphic from the slide prior
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at as your hybrid
benefit so many customers have invested
already in Windows servers licenses and
they want to repurpose their investment
on a sure this happens because
enterprises have been working with
Microsoft servers even before Azure
existed or they were on-premise
originally and so they wanted to use the
software so they purchased a licenses
but now they're ready to move on to a
sure
and so since they've already got a
special deal with Microsoft because they
purchased those licenses they want to
keep those deals and bring them to the
cloud so that's where the as your hybrid
benefit comes into play also abbreviated
as hub sometimes it's called as your
hybrid use benefit in Microsoft
documentation but for some reason as
your they just drop the word use but the
abbreviation is hub so this gives
customers the the right to use these
licenses for virtual machines on Azure
and so such types of virtual machines
would be Windows servers or SQL servers
and I would imagine this would probably
happen with the lift and shift which I
think we described somewhere in this
course so hub can be turned off on and
off at any time for existing virtual
machines and hub can be applied at
deployment time for new VMs and I just
wrote bring your own license down here
just because we are talking about
licensing and I just wanted to get you
more exposure to that term bring your
own license
BYO l and so that just means that
someone's purchased a license and they
want to apply it they want to bring it
on - azure so there you go that is as
your hybrid benefit so I just want to
quickly show you this page here which is
the azure hybrid benefit page if you're
detecting to Google as your hybrid
benefit you definitely make your way
here what I wanted to show you is that
they actually have this nice little
calculator down below so if you do have
licenses and you're bringing them over
and you want to run workloads on Azure
you can fill this stuff out and it'll
give you an idea of what you might save
so I just wanted to make you aware of
that so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Azure subscription
so as your subscription I would describe
as the equivalent of saying my Azure
account I don't know why they use the
term subscription because to me it's
just confusing but I always just try to
reinforce that it's just your account
and there are four tiers of as your
subscriptions the first is the free
subscription so when you first sign up
this is the the account the u're
subscription you're gonna have you have
to provide a credit card to complete the
process
you're gonna get 200 USD credits free
for 30 days and certain Azure products
will be free for twelve months now the
whole point of this free subscription is
to help you avoid charges and there are
some limitations I remember when I was
trying to add another user
I couldn't grant them access so there
was definitely some some limitations
here too to prevent you from being
charged but it's not a complete sandbox
so it is possible to get charges count
if you start using things outside the
free tier or if you burn through your
credit so just be careful there and then
once you are ready to switch or to
upgrade and unlock everything then you
can switch to page you go subscription
also abbreviated to PAYG some people
might call that on-demand and so for
this you still need a credit card
required but since you've already
entered it in the free subscription
stage no problem here you're gonna be
charged at the end of the month based on
unconsumed
cloud resources then you have an
enterprise agreement so if you are
enterprise you can make a deal - and
agree to receive a discounted price for
licenses and cloud service but I bet
you're paying a lot of money like
compared to the normal person but the
deal is worth it for you so just be
aware if your enterprise go talk to you
Ashera they want to make a deal and the
last is the student subscription so the
student subscription you do not require
a credit card you get hundred dollars
USD creds for 12 months but it requires
a valid student email so there is a
little bit of a vetting process there so
you definitely have to be in school to
get that but it is a very nice option to
have so there you go that is the Azure
subscription models
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and we are looking at as your pricing
calculator so configure it estimate the
cost of azure products you don't have to
sign in to use this tool and and what
you can do is download Excel spreadsheet
and share that those costs with your
boss so to get there you go to Azure dot
Microsoft comm four slash pricing
forward slash calculator and from there
you can you can go in here and you can
fill out different things so there's a
bunch of different categories that
what's common would probably be a
virtual machine so you go in there and
you say what region it's gonna launch
and what OS and all the types of
configuration it's going to give you an
estimated cost so this one down below is
an upfront cost of $0 with a monthly
cost of 150 2.62 dollars if you're not
sure how to make sense of all the
pricing go here and play around and you
will get a clear picture of what you're
gonna spend on Azure so I just wanted to
show you the pricing calculator so if
you just went to Google and typed in
Azure pricing calculator you should be
able to make your way to this page and
so down below we have a bunch of
products we also have example scenarios
which is a very nice to see here so
let's say we wanted a CI CT pipeline
here and we said add to estimate we
could get that information for all these
components I'm just going to go to
single products because it's a bit
easier to view so let's say we want to
determine our costs for storage so let's
just go to storage here and we will try
storage accounts and then down below
we've now added storage and so we can
enter some information to try to
determine our costs so we can do blob
file storage table storage I'm gonna go
with file storage
actually now I'm gonna go with blob it's
just easier to calculate and so we're
gonna have the performance tier 2
premium we're done CLRS and we're gonna
be e east us and so if we had a thousand
gigabytes I guess it's a terabyte that's
$150 if we had X amount of write
operations X amount of list and create
container operations read operations and
here we'd have $150 as a monthly cost so
here you just have to tweak it based on
your consumptions and then generally
they'll show you like purchase options
really this just means like go sign up
for an azure account but I just wanted
to show you what that looks like and
just so that you know that you can go
explore any cost and try to calculate
something before you use it
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at as your cost
management and so this service allows
you to perform cost analysis so you can
visualize the spending of your Adric
cloud resources but you can also create
a budget under the service so when you
set a budget you're gonna yeah you're
gonna define a threshold and you're
gonna be alerted when you're approaching
or you've exceeded that threshold and so
just to give you a visual representation
there that is for the cost analysis so
you can see you get beautiful graphs and
you can drill down and filter that stuff
out to really understand how you were
spending stuff on Azure so definitely
check it out and there you go hey this
is Angie Brown from exam Pro I'm gonna
show you how to book your exam for the
AZ 900 so what I want you to do is type
in Pearson VUE asher or Pearson VUE
Microsoft into Google and you should
make your way to this page and then what
you're gonna want to do is on the right
hand side go ahead there and click log
in then it's gonna ask what
certification you want and type into AZ
900 and so there is the certification
there then we're gonna see this page
that's going to show some intermediate
information about the certification what
we're gonna do is go ahead and schedule
a Pearson VUE now there is the sort of
Certiport but that's if you're a student
or an instructor we are neither so we
are going to be choosing the Pearson VUE
mode there's this drop down here that
literally does nothing I don't know why
they have it here I thought maybe it
would change the price maybe it would
change the availability but if based on
where you are but we'll go ahead there
and hit schedule with Pearson VUE what's
going to do is ask us to log in to our
Microsoft account mine is called as your
exam procow it's the same account I
created when I created my Azure account
and then I'm just going to put my
password in there we'll hit sign in and
then the next step is it's going to ask
me to fill in my certification profile
so this is all personal information
relating to me and notice that you have
to enter in exactly as your
government-issued identification so you
can book the exam so I'm going to fill
this in and perceive the net
step and I'll see you there all right so
we're onto the next step here and so we
finished my profile separate exam
discounts I'm not a Microsoft employee I
didn't attend event so I'm knocking any
cool discounts here so we're just going
to go ahead and proceed to a Pearson VUE
to schedule our exam so just wait here a
moment and so now that we're on to here
it's going to ask how do you want to
exam at a local test center at my home
office or private access cloud I'm going
to show you how to do it at a local test
center we might not have any options
here but we'll give it a go and we're
gonna choose our language English is the
case here and it's going to say the
price and etc we'll go to next and so
what it's going to do is it's going to
show me locations that are nearby to me
so down below you have a graph and you
have some stuff there so we'll just take
a look here and so what I can do is I
can click on a location so I'm just
going to choose the Mississauga Center
that one's pretty good so I'm going to
go ahead and check box app and we're
gonna have to select at least three test
centers here so I'm gonna choose this
one and that one
it'll proceed to next and so now we have
some options here to schedule I want the
Mississauga one will have to go back to
this one here and then we will choose
our time
and so from there all we have to do is
add to order pay and there you go so
that's all it takes to book your exam so
good luck on your exam